[ CAPTIONING TEST ]
>> GOOD MORNING.
I FEEL LIKE I'M INTERRUPTING
RECESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT, BUT
I'M EXCITED TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
WELCOME YOU THIS MORNING TO THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I'M LEE ANN POTTER.
I DIRECT THE OFFICE OF LEARNING
AND INNOVATION HERE, AND IT
REALLY IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
YOU THIS MORNING ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL SPRING DAY.
I THINK THE STARS MUST BE
ALIGNED BECAUSE IT IS A PERFECT
SPRING MORNING TO BE HERE IN
WASHINGTON, SO YOU GUYS ARE
CHARMED.
AS YOU KNOW, TODAY WE'RE HERE
FOR OUR SYMPOSIUM FIRST ON
DIVERSITY IN CHILDREN'S
LITERATURE, FOLLOWED BY THE
WALTER AWARDS.
THE PROGRAM THIS MORNING IS
ENTITLED --
READ, DISCOVER, GROW.
AND IT IS BEING CO-HOSTED BY
BOTH THE LIBRARY, AND WE NEED
DIVERSE BOOKS.
I THINK WE NEED TO DO A GOOD
SHOUT-OUT TO "WE NEED DIVERSE
BOOKS."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW, WE NEED
DIVERSE BOOKS IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WHOSE AIM IS TO
HELP PRODUCE AND PROMOTE
LITERATURE THAT REFLECTS AND
HONORS THE LIVES OF ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE.
YAY!
THIS PROGRAM IS BEING
LIVESTREAMED SO IF YOU WANT TO
DO A SHOUT-OUT TO YOUR NIECES
AND NEPHEWS AND CHILDREN AND
SISTERS AND BROTHERS, NOW IS
YOUR CHANCE.
GO AHEAD AND WAVE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I DO THAT WITH
KIDS, THEY GET ALL OVER IT.
JUST SAYING.
I DO WANT TO THANK OUR AUDIENCE
AT A DISTANCE FOR JOINING US, AS
WELL, ESPECIALLY THOSE IN TIME
ZONES OTHER THAN HOURS.
FOR THOSE MOKES IN THE MOUNTAIN
TIME ZONE, AND ON THE WEST
COAST, IT'S A REALLY EARLY
MORNING FOR THEM SO THANKS TO
THOSE AT A DISTANCE.
THANK YOU AS WELL TO COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE IN THIS ROOM WHO ARE
MAKING THIS LIVE STREAM HAPPEN
AND MAKING THIS RECORDING
HAPPEN.
MAGIC LIKE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
BY ITSELF, SO THANK YOU, GUYS.
I'M EXCITED TO INTRODUCE THIS
MORNING'S PANEL MODERATOR, BUT
BEFORE I DO, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
A LITTLE SHORT STORY.
MY PARENTS THINK IT'S HORRIBLE
THAT I NO LONGER SUBSCRIBE TO A
REGULAR DAILY NEWSPAPER.
SO WHEN THEY COME TO VISIT, THEY
MAKE SURE THAT "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" WEEKEND EDITION IS AT
MY HOUSE, AND SO THEY'VE NOW
GOTTEN US A SUBSCRIPTION TO THE
WEEKEND EDITION OF THE JOURNAL
SO IT'S ALWAYS THERE AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT I'VE GOTTEN IN
THE HABIT OF READING IT EVERY
SATURDAY MORNING, ESPECIALLY THE
REVIEW SECTION AND I HAPPEN TO
HAVE MY LITTLE CUT-OUT HERE OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" REVIEW
SECTION FROM FEBRUARY 2 OF THIS
YEAR, AND THIS IS WHERE MY STORY
COMES IN.
SO ON THAT SATURDAY, FEBRUARY 2,
WHILE READING THE REVIEW SECTION
OF THE JOURNAL, I CAME ACROSS AN
ARTICLE ENTITLED HANDING OUT THE
HARDWARE.
IN IT I READ THE FOLLOWING --
EACH YEAR THE NEWBERY MEDAL GOES
TO THE BOOK CORD BY THE
SELECTION COMMITTEE TO BE THE
MOST DISTINGUISHED CONTRIBUTION
TO AMERICAN LITERATURE FOR
CHILDREN.
THIS YEAR, IT WENT TO MEG
MEDINA'S KINNED-HEARTED NOVEL
FOR -- KIND HEARTED NOVEMBER EL
FOR 9 TO 12-YEAR-OLDS.
ALTHOUGH THE ARTICLE CONTINUED,
I SIMPLY SQUEALED AND SHOUTED
FOR THE REST OF MY FAMILY TO
HEAR:  HEY, I KNOW HER!
THIS IS COOL!
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND IT IS COOL.
MEG MEDINA IS A GOOD FRIEND TO
THE LIBRARY AND I AM GLAD THAT
MY PATH HAS CROSSED WITH HERS ON
A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS.
SHE IS THE 2019 JOHN NEWBERY
MEDAL RECIPIENT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SHE IS ALSO A CUBAN AMERICAN
AUTHOR WHO WRITES PICTURE BOOKS,
MIDDLE GRADE AND YOUNG ADULT
FICTION.
HER YA NOVELS INCLUDE BURN BABY
BURN, AND THE GIRL WHO SILENCED
THE WIND.
HER PICTURE BOOKS INTRUDE TIAISA
WANTS A CAR.
MEG'S WORKS HAVE BEEN CALLED
HEART BREAKING, LYRICAL AND MUST
HAVES FOR EVERY COLLECTION.
IN ADDITION THOUGH THE NEWBERY
THEY EARNED HER OTHER MEDALS AND
HONORS.
HER WORKS HAVE ALSO BEEN LONG
LISTED FOR THE NATIONAL BOOK
AWARD AND WERE TWICE NAMED AS
FINALISTS FOR THE PRESTIGE
KIRKAS PRIZE FOR FICTION.
HER WORK EXAMINES HOW CULTURES
INTERSECT AS SEEN THROUGH THE
EYES OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHEN SHE'S NOT WRITING MEG WORKS
ON COMMUNITY PROJECTS THAT
SUPPORT GIRLS, LATINO YOUTH
AND/OR LITERACY.
SHE LIVES WITH HEIFER FAMILY IN
RICHMOND, VIRGINIA -- WITH HER
FAMILY, IN RICHMOND VIRGINIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MEG
MEDINA, WHO WILL BE SERVING AS
OUR PANEL MODERATOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BUENOS DIA: IT'S SO NICE TO
BE HERE THIS MORNING.
AND I WANT TO CALL UP MY FRIENDS
TO JOIN ME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
WELCOME.
HI EVERYBODY AT HOME AND ON THE
WEST COAST AND WELCOME TO THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE WITH US
TODAY.
I HAVE VERY SHORT BIOS.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
THESE EXQUISITE PEOPLE IN A
MOMENT BUT FOR NOW WHEN I CALL
YOU, JUST COME ON UP, PLEASE.
THE FIRST PERSON IS TIFFANY
JACKSON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
TIFFANY IS THE AUTHOR OF THE
CRITICALLY ACCLAIMED ALLEGEDLY
AND MONDAY'S NOT COMING WHICH
RECENTLY WON THE CORETTA SCOTT
KING NEW TALENT AWARD.
A TV PROFESSIONAL BY DAY,
NOVELIST BY NIGHT.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
SHE RECEIVED HER B.A. FROM
HOWARD UNIVERSITY AND HER M.A.
IN MEDIA STUDIES FROM THE NEW
SCHOOL.
WOO!
MAWS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NECKS UP, EMILY X.R. PAN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
EMILY IS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLING AUTHOR OF A BOOK I
LOVE, THE ASTONISHING COLOR OF
AFTER, WHICH WAS A FINALIST ALSO
FOR THE LOS ANGELES TIMES BOOK
PRIZE.
OOH!
LONG LISTED FOR THE CARNEGIE
MEDAL, AND I'M SORRY, AND SHE
WAS THE RECIPIENT OF THE APAWA
HONOR AWARD.
EMILY CURRENTLY LIVES IN
BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, BUT WAS
ORIGINALLY FROM TH MID AND
BORN TO IMMIGRANT PARENTS FROM
TAIWAN.
NEXT UP, DAVID BOWLES, COME ON
UP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAVID IS A MEXICAN AMERICAN
AUTHOR FROM SOUTH TEXAS WHERE HE
TEACHES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
HIS BOOKS RECEIVED HONORS AND
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED ON KIRKAS
BEST YA BOOKS 2018, AND LAST
BUT DEFINITELY NOT LEAST, VEERA
HIRANANDANI.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
VEERA IS THE AUTHOR OF THE NIGHT
DIARY WHICH RECEIVED A NEWBERY
HONOR THIS YEAR, AND THE
2018MALCA PENN AWARD FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN CHILDREN'S
LITERATURE^.
SHE'S A FORMER BOOK EDITOR AT
SIMON AND SCHUSTER AND NOW
TEACHES CREATIVE WRITING AT
SARAH LAWRENCE COLLEGE WRITING
INSTITUTE.
PLEASE GIVE THEM ALL A BIG
ROUND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO THIS IS HOW IT'S GOING TO
WORK, PEOPLE:  I DON'T LIKE
PODIUMS SO I'M GOING TO GO SIT
WITH MY FRIENDS, AND WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A CHAT.
I HAVE GIVEN THEM A SNEAK PEEK
INTO QUESTIONS, BUT THE IDEA IS
FOR US TO INTERRUPT EACH OTHER,
TO ADD TO EACH OTHER'S COMMENTS,
TO TAKE US ON WILD EXCURSIONS
AWAY FROM THESE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S FREE-FLOWING AND
I THINK THEY'RE GAME BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL BOOK PEOPLE AND THEY
LOVE US, SO I SAY WE'RE IN,
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT, HERE I GO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY, IS MY MIC ON?
YOU CAN HEAR ME.
OKAY, SO THE FIRST THING I WAS
CURIOUS ABOUT, BECAUSE ALL OF
YOUR NOVELS WERE -- HAD SUCH
VOICE, ALL OF THEM.
WE HAVE A NOVEL ABOUT A GIRL AT
THE TIME OF PARTITION, WRITING A
DIARY TO HER MOM WHO'S NO LONGER
LIVING.
WE HAVE A BOY TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF HIS LIFE AND HIS FAMILY
AND HIS IDENTITY.
WE HAVE A GIRL STRUGGLING WITH
HER MOTHER'S SUICIDE.
WE HAVE A STORY OF A GIRL TRYING
TO MAKE SENSE AND DISCOVER THE
REASONS BEHIND THE DISAPPEARANCE
OF A DEAR FRIEND.
AND WHAT CAME ACROSS TO ME FOR
ALL OF THEM IS JUST THE SENSE OF
VOICE.
I THINK THE FIRST THING I WANT
TO ASK YOU IS, FOR YOU, IN YOUR
NOVELS, WHERE DID YOU FIND THIS
PERSON THAT WAS GOING TO LEAD
THAT NOVEL?
WHERE WAS YOUR PROTAGONIST?
HOW DID YOU FIND THEM?
DID YOU FIND STORY FIRST, OR THE
PERSON FIRST?
GIVE US SOME SENSE OF THAT.
AND I'M GOING TO PICK ON POOR
TIFFANY.
YOU'RE CLOSEST.
SHE'S LIKE NO, NO, NOT ME, NOT
ME CLAM.
>> I WAS SNEAKILY TRYING TO SAY
IT WITH MY EYES, LIKE "NO."
SO THE MAIN PROTAGONIST IN
MONDAY'S NOT COMING HER NAME IS
CLAUDIA, AND HONESTLY I SORT OF
DIALED INTO MYSELF, ME AS A
CHILD.
I WAS A RELATIVELY SHY CHILD.
I HAD A BEST FRIEND.
I DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO SHARE
WITH ANYONE.
I STILL DON'T LIKE TO SHARE MY
TOYS TODAY.
I ALSO HAD A LEARNING
DISABILITY, AND I LIVED IN MY
OWN BUBBLE, SO IT WAS REALLY
ACTUALLY EASY FOR ME TO WRITE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, BECAUSE IT
WAS EASY FOR ME TO JUST DIAL
INTO MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES, TO FIND THAT KID
THAT I PRETENDED NOT TO BE, BUT
I TRULY WAS WHEN I LOOK BACK ON
HER.
>> ANYBODY ELSE?
WHERE DID YOU FIND YOURSELF?
>> FOR ME, I STARTED WITH THE
STORY, WHICH IS I KNOW VERY ODD
BECAUSE THE BOOK IS SO
CHARACTER-DRIVEN BUT I KNEW THAT
I WANTED TO WRITE ABOUT A GIRL
WHO WAS HEARING HER
GRANDMOTHER'S STORIES FOR THE
FIRST TIME BECAUSE MY
GRANDMOTHER IN MY BOOK IS
SHAMELESSLY RIPPED OFF MY
GRANDMOTHER, LIKE BASICALLY
COPY/PASTE SO I HAD THIS GAP OF
THIS CHARACTER TO FILL IN.
THEN IT TOOK ME MANY YEARS TO
START TO DIVE INTO MYSELF.
IT TOOK ME A REALLY LONG TIME TO
BE WILLING TO GO THERE.
I THINK I WAS REALLY AFRAID AT
FIRST.
I THINK IN THE BEGINNING, I WAS
LIKE, OH, I'M GOING TO WRITE
ABOUT THIS TOTALLY FICTIONAL
PERSON, COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
FROM ME, BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
TO THE DIG UP SHADOWS AND
EXPLORE ALL THESE THINGS THAT
WERE CONFLICTS IN MY BRAIN, WERE
THINGS I WAS TRYING TO WRESTLE
WITH MYSELF.
AND SO THAT WAS AN INTERESTING
PROCESS.
I WROTE MANY, MANY DRAFTS AND
FINALLY ARRIVED AT A PLACE WHERE
I WAS LIKE, OH, I HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT ME AND MY EXPERIENCE WITH
MY FAMILY, AND WHAT IT FELT LIKE
TO STRADDLE DIFFERENT IDENTITIES
GROWING UP.
>> SO THAT WAS THE THING THAT
WAS KEEPING YOU, THAT NOTION OF
IDENTITY AND FEAR?
WAS THAT -- AM I HEARING THAT
RIGHT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IN ORIGINAL
DRAFTS OF THE BOOK, MY CHARACTER
WAS VERY, VERY -- EVERY SINGLE
TIME I REWROTE THE BOOK IT WAS
COMPLETELY A DIFFERENT CAST OF
CHARACTERS EXCEPT FOR THE
GRANDMOTHER'S CHARACTER BECAUSE
SHE WAS MY GRANDMOTHER.
>> EMILY, THAT'S A LOT OF PAGES.
>> IT IS A LOT OF PAGES AND A
LOT OF CHARACTERS AND WHEN I
FINALLY LANDED UPON LEE'S
CHARACTER, IT BECAME THIS WAY OF
EXPRESSING AND EXPLORING ALL
THESE THINGS THAT I DIDN'T EVEN
REALIZE I WAS STILL WRESTLING
WITH FROM MY CHILDHOOD OF NOT
QUITE FITTING INTO THIS CULTURE
AND NOT QUITE FITTING INTO THAT
CULTURE AND TRYING TO FIND MY
PLACE IN THE WORLD.
>> AND HOW ABOUT,.
>> THEY CALL ME BUERO DIDN'T
BEGIN AS A NOVEL AT FIRST.
IT WAS MEANT TO BE A CHARACTER
STUDY, A CHECK TON HARD OF
HEARING SHUN OF POEMS IN A BOY'S
VOICE TO GET ACROSS THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN IDENTITY AND TRY TO
BREAK WITH THE STEREOTYPES AND
PUSH BACK AGAINST SOME OF THE
NOISE WE HEAR IN SOCIETY RIGHT
NOW.
THE FIRST POEM I WROTE, IT WAS
BEFORE I THOUGHT OF THE IDEA OF
THE BOOK, IT WAS A POEM CALLED
BORDER KID FOR AN ANTHOLOGY
RIGHT AFTER THE ELECTION THAT
HELPED KIDS OF COLOR WHO WERE
KIND OF DISTRAUGHT ABOUT THE
THINGS THEY WERE HEARING, THE
LEADERS OF OUR COUNTRY SAYING,
TO GRAPPLE WITH THEIR ANXIETY
THROUGH POETRY SO I WROTE THIS
POEM CALLED BORDER KID, AND IT
WAS REPRINTED IN THE JOURNAL OF
CHILDREN'S LITERATURE AND I READ
IT WHEN I WAS INDUCTED INTO THE
TEXAS INSTITUTE OF LETTERS AND
AS I WAS COMING DOWN OFF THE
STAGE AN EDITOR CAME UP TO ME
AND SAID I LOVE THAT POEM AND IF
YOU CAN WRITE ANOTHER 50 POEMS
IN THAT KID'S VOICE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-- I'LL PUBLISH IT.
THAT WAS NOT ON MY WRITING
CALENDAR, BUT -- SO I SAT DOWN
AND STARTED TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHO THIS KID WAS, AND I REALIZED
THAT WHILE HIS IDENTITY
INTERSECTED WITH MINE, HE WAS
ALSO PARTLY MY SON, PARTLY THE
BOYS THAT I HAD TAUGHT WHEN I
WAS A MIDDLE-SCHOOL TEACHER FOR
9 YEARS, PARTLY JUST THE
OTHER -- MY COUSINS AND OTHER
MUCH
ASOS, AND BIT BY BIT THIS
COMPLEX REAL HUMAN CHARACTER
JUST BLOSSOMED AND AFTER A WHILE
I HEARD HIS VOICE THAT THE POEMS
CAME NATURALLY AND POURED OUT OF
ME.
IT'S A GIFT WHEN THAT HAPPENS
AND THAT'S AN AMALGAMATION OF
ALL THESE WONDERFUL THINGS ABOUT
BEING A MEXICAN AMERICAN BOY ON
THE BORDER, A KID WHO'S KIND OF
A NERD.
HE'S MISCHIEVOUS, BUT HE HAS A
GOOD HEART, HE DOESN'T MEAN ANY
REAL MALICE ABOUT IT.
HE'S BEGINNING TO FALL IN LOVE
THE FIRST TIME AND HE'S DEEPLY
ROOTED IN HIS COMMUNITY BUT HE'S
A MEXICAN AMERICAN KID IN 2019
SO HE'S GRAPPLING WITH ALL KINDS
OF BULLYING AT THE LOCAL AND
NATIONAL LEVEL.
HE HAS A TEACHER WHO HELPS HIM
DISCOVER IT AND HE FINDS HIS
VOICE AND I FOUND HIS VOICE AND
IT'S NICE FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE 50 POEMS
IS HARD TO WRITE WITHOUT A
VOICE.
HE CAME THROUGH.
VEERA, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT IDEA OF SORT OF FINDING
YOUR VOICE AND FINDING YOUR
CHARACTER'S VOICE AND IT'S SORT
OF TWO DIFFERENT -- AND THEN
YOUR CHARACTER FINDING THEIR
VOICE.
THERE ARE ALL THESE LAYERS OF
VOICE YOU'RE UNEARTHING AND I
STARTED THE NIGHT DIARY KIND OF
REALLY WAY BACK, AND I KNEW THAT
I WANTED TO WRITE A STORY ABOUT
THE 1947 PARTITION OF INDIA.
I WANTED IT TO BE INSPIRED BY MY
OWN FATHER'S EXPERIENCES AND MY
FATHER'S FAMILY'S EXPERIENCES
BUT I REALLY WASN'T SURE HOW TO
ACCESS IT AND SO I STARTED
ACTUALLY WITH A YOUNG MALE
CHARACTER AND I WAS IN THIRD
PERSON.
MY VERY EARLY SKETCHES AND AS I
WAS KIND OF WRITING PIECES I
REALIZED I WAS TRYING TO WRITE
MY FATHER'S STORY WHICH IS NOT
REALLY WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
I WANTED IT TO HAVE THAT
CONNECTION BUT I ALSO NEEDED A
MORE PERSONAL CONNECTION WITH
THE MAIN CHARACTER AND I MOVED
THAT MALE CHARACTER OVER AND
NISHA KIND OF BLOSSOMED, THE
MAIN CHARACTER AND I KNEW
SOMEHOW SHE WAS VERY QUIET, VERY
SHY AND WOULD HAVE TROUBLE
TALKING WITH PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
HER FAMILY BUT SHE WOULD BE ABLE
TO EXPRESS HERSELF IN A DIARY
AND FIND HER VOICE THAT WAY AND
CREATING NISHA WRITING IN HER
DIARY HELPED ME FIGURE OUT KIND
OF MY VOICE FOR THE BOOK AND HER
VOICE AND HER FINDING HER VOICE
SO ALL THOSE LAYERS.
>> WHICH BRINGS US, I WAS
THINKING ALSO ABOUT JUST THE
FORM, THE WAY YOU GUYS DECIDED
TO TELL YOUR STORY BECAUSE
THAT'S A THING, RIGHT?
YOU'RE SITTING THERE AND YOU
COULD TELL THE SAME STORY IN SO
NOVEL, YOU'RE TELLING IT THROUGH
A DIARY, SO YOU GUYS PLAYED WITH
TIME, SOMETIMES CHRONOLOGY,
SOMETIMES MAGICAL REALISM.
HOW DID YOU DECIDE ON YOUR FORM?
DID THAT -- I HEAR NOW HOW VEERA
DID IT BUT HOW ABOUT THE REST OF
YOU?
DID YOU, WAS THAT CONSCIOUS?
DID YOU EXPERIMENT WITH OTHER
WAYS OF TELLING THIS STORY?
OR DID IT FLOW PRETTY MUCH FROM
THE BEGINNING?
>> YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME AGAIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU'LL FORGIVE ME ONE DAY,
TIFFANY.
>> SO MONDAY'S NOT COMING IS
TOLD IN A SERIES OF BEFORES AND
AFTERS, SO IT'S BEFORE MONDAY'S
DISAPPEARANCE AND AFTER AND I
DID THAT HONESTLY FOR A
THREE-FOLD REASON, ONE, I REALLY
WANTED EVERYONE TO GET TO KNOW
MONDAY AND CLAUDIA.
I WANTED THEM TO GET TO KNOW
THEIR RELATIONSHIP.
I WANTED THEM TO SEE IT BUILD
AND SEE IT BLOSSOM AND SEE HOW
BEST FRIENDS COULD REALLY LOVE
EACH OTHER, AND, TWO, OR A
SECOND REASON, IS I DIDN'T
WANT -- SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I
WRITE THRILLERS, AND IF YOU
NOTICE, A LOT OF THRILLERS
THERE'S ALWAYS SORT OF LIKE A
DEAD GIRL IN THE BACKGROUND AND
SHE'S NOT REALLY TALKED ABOUT
AND I DIDN'T WANT MONDAY TO BE
JUST ANOTHER DEAD GIRL.
I WANTED HER TO ACTUALLY LIKE
REALLY THRIVE ON THE PAGE FOR
YOU TO GET TO KNOW HER.
SO WHENEVER THE OUTCOME OF THE
STORY IS, YOU'RE MORE AFFECTED
BY IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE GIRL.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE A PHANTOM
PERSON.
THREE, I REALLY WANTED THIS
STORY TO BE AN EXPERIENCE.
SO I WANTED -- OF COURSE, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE CHAPTERS ARE SORT
OF ALL OVER THE PLACE BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY HOW CLAUDIA WAS FEELING.
SHE WAS DISTURBED.
SHE WAS FRUSTRATED.
SHE WAS CONFUSED.
SHE WAS DEALING WITH HER OWN
LEARNING DISABILITY.
SHE WAS DEALING WITH THE FACT
THAT SHE HAD A BEST FRIEND THAT
WAS MISSING, AND FELT LIKE NO
ONE ELSE SEEMED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
SO I WANTED HER FEELINGS TO
REALLY -- I WANTED THE READER'S
FEELINGS TO PARALLEL CLAUDIA'S
FEELINGS.
SO THAT WAS SORT OF LIKE, IT WAS
SORT OF A THREE-FOLD KIND OF,
YOU KNOW, A MIXED STEW THERE.
>> IT WAS CHALLENGING THOUGH.
MANIPULATING TIME THAT WAY, IT
WAS TRICKY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I MEAN, AND TO BE HONEST, I
DIDN'T ORIGINALLY WRITE IT THAT
WAY.
I ACTUALLY WROTE IT IN
CHRONOLOGICAL ORDER AND OF
COURSE LIKE MANY OF MY BOOKS I
COME UP WITH AN IDEA OUT OF
NOWHERE AND I WOKE UP AT 2:00 IN
THE MORNING AND I WAS LIKE OH,
WE SHOULD DO IT THIS WAY AND
THAT'S LITERALLY WHAT I DID.
HONESTLY THE ONLY REASON I WAS
ABLE TO REMOTELY DO IT AND NOT
DRIVE MYSELF CRAZY IS BECAUSE I
HAVE A FILM BACKGROUND SO I TAKE
EVERY CHAPTER AND CONSIDER IT
LIKE A SCENE SO I WAS ABLE TO
REARRANGE EVERYTHING JUST LIKE
YOU'D DO IN THE EDIT ROOM.
THAT WAS THE ONLY WAY.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE LIKE OH, TEACH
ME HOW TO DO THIS, I WAS LIKE...
>> GET A MEDIA DEGREE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS ALSO THAT I WANTED TO
RANGE ON, WAS ALL OF YOU HAVE
THESE COLORFUL, INCREDIBLE
BACKGROUNDS, PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUNDS.
LIKE, YOU'VE DONE OTHER STUFF,
TV.
BUT VEERA WAS AN EDITOR.
DAVID'S A PROFESSOR.
SO, LIKE, I'M WONDERING, LIKE,
HOW DO YOUR PAST EXPERIENCES,
HOW DID THEY HELP SHAPE HOW YOU
ATTACKED MAYBE THE STRUCTURE OF
THE NOVEL AND SO ON?
SO I SEE CERTAINLY THE FILM PART
OF IT, AND HOW YOU WOULD TELL A
STORY LIKE THIS, AND TO SAY THAT
YOU WRITE A THRILLER IS THE
BIGGEST UNDERSTATEMENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I READ THIS BOOK, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, IN TERROR, BASICALLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO JUST BE WARNED.
BUT I DEFINITELY SAW THAT, SO
HOW DO YOUR PAST EXPERIENCES,
HOW DID IT HELP YOU TELL IT IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU PICKED THE FORM
FORM?
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU JUST MADE THE
QUESTION SO MUCH HARDER.
>> EVERYONE ON THIS END HAD
ALREADY PREPARED ANSWERS.
>> WHOEVER WANTS TO JUMP IN, YOU
CAN BE BRAVE.
>> MY BACKGROUND IS KIND OF ALL
OVER THE PLACE AND I FEEL LIKE
MY BOOK IS KIND OF ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
>> GOOD!
YAY!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I WISH I COULD WRITE, LIKE, A
BOOK THAT'S LINEAR, CHRONOLOGY,
START TO FINISH.
MY LIFE WOULD BE SO MUCH EASIER
BUT I START WRITING, AND I
IMMEDIATELY GET BORED, AND I'VE
GOT TO THROW A WRENCH INTO
THINGS.
I'VE GOT TO THROW ANOTHER WRENCH
INTO THINGS AND SUDDENLY I'M
JUGGLING MULTIPLE TIME LINES AND
I'M LIKE, WHAT'S GOING ON?
AND FOR ME, IT WAS ALSO THAT --
I SORT OF HINTED UPON HOW I DO
ITERATIVE DRAFTING, SO MY DRAFTS
TEND TO LOOK HUGELY DIFFERENT
FROM PREVIOUS DRAFTS, AND SO
WHEN WE -- WHEN MY AGENT AND I
SOLD THE BOOK, IT ACTUALLY WAS
MORE OF A FANTASY NOVEL.
IT CUT BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN A
FANTASY WORLD AND THE REAL WORLD
AND IT WAS ALL BRAIDED TOGETHER
AND THEN THERE WERE DIFFERENT
TIME LINES WITHIN THOSE, ALSO,
AND THEN I REALIZED THE FANTASY
WORLD REALLY WASN'T WORKING THE
WAY I WANTED IT TO.
IT SORT OF TOOK THE WEIGHT OUT
OF THE STORY I WAS REALLY TRYING
TO TELL, SO I ENDED UP STRIPPING
THAT ENTIRELY OUT OF THE BOOK,
BUT I STILL NEEDED TO SOMEHOW BE
ABLE TO ACCESS MEMORIES FROM THE
PAST, BECAUSE IN THE BOOK, LI
GETS THESE MEMORIES THAT BELONG
TO OTHER PEOPLE THAT SHE
COULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN ANY OTHER
WAY EXCEPT VIA MAGICAL MEANS,
AND SO THROUGH THAT, THE NEED TO
FILL THAT KIND OF GUIDED MY TIME
LINE AND MY JUMPING AROUND.
AND THEN I ENDED UP WITH, YOU
KNOW, ALSO A BIG STEW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BIG CANS OF STEW UP HERE.
>> WE LIKE FOOD.
>> IT'S FUN TO SEE HOW IT ALL
WORKS.
HOW ABOUT YOU GUYS?
>> WELL, AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS AN
ENGLISH TEACHER FOR 14 YEARS AND
AFTER I GOT MY DOCTORATE I WAS
IN CHARGE OF AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS PROGRAM AND ESL BILINGUAL
PROGRAM IN AN ENTIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND NOW I'M TEACHING AT
A UNIVERSITY.
WHEN THE IDEA CAME FOR ME TO
WRITE A BUNCH OF POEMS IN THIS
KID'S VOICE I STARTED THINKING
AS A TEACHER:  WHAT DO TEACHERS
NEED FROM A BOOK OF MIDDLE GRADE
POETRY?
WHAT WOULD THEY LIKE TO HAVE?
THEY'VE GOT TO TEACH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT FORMS AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT, LIKE, ELEMENTS OF
PROSIDY SO MAYBE I CAN HAVE HIM
PLAYING AROUND WITH FORMAL
POETRY BECAUSE SO MANY NOVELS
WILL BE WRITTEN IN FREE VERSE.
LET ME DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
BEFORE I KNEW IT WOULD BE A
NOVEL IN THE FIRST I HAD HIM
EXPERIMENTING WITH WRITING A SON
NET, WITH WRITING DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MORE METERED POETRY
AND SO FORTH AND THE COLLECTION
WAS BROKEN UP INTO SECTIONS AND
THE INITIAL CHRONOLOGICAL
SECTION THAT WAS MORE FREE VERSE
AND SECTIONS WHERE HE'S
EXPERIMENTING WITH DIFFERENT
FORMS AND WRITING ABOUT
CELEBRATIONS AND PEOPLE IN HIS
FAMILY AND SO FORTH.
AND AS I WAS WRITING ALL THIS,
IT WAS REALLY, REALLY A LOT OF
FUN BUT I HANDED OFF THE ROUGH
DRAFT TO MY EDITOR AND HE'S
LIKE, WELL, THIS IS A GREAT
EXERCISE IN, YOU KNOW, CREATING
A TEXTBOOK OR SOMETHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'VE GOT TO START THINKING
ABOUT THE TEACHERS, ABOUT THE
STUDENTS CLEARLY, AND THEN HE
WAS THE ONE WHO SHOWED ME LOOK,
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A NARRATIVE
THREAD HERE, A STORY THAT WANTS
TO BE TOLD.
REARRANGE ALL THIS STUFF IN
CHRONOLOGICAL ORDER AND LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AND SEE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE AND START FILLING THOSE
IN, AND HE STARTED MAKING
SUGGESTIONS FOR CHANGES TO SOME
OF THE POEMS, OR THINGS NOR ME
TO THINK ABOUT, THAT WERE
DISRUPTING WHATEVER FORM THE
POEM WAS BEING WRITTEN IN.
SO SOME OF THE POEMS ARE WEIRD
FUSIONS OF AN ORIGINAL FORMAL
POEM AND THEN SOME, LIKE,
FREE-VERSE ELEMENTS.
I'M VERY HAPPY WITH THE FINAL
THING, BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
GO INTO IT THINKING, AH, I WANT
TO MAKE SOMETHING THAT HAS
UTILITY FOR TEACHERS, IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS TURN OUT QUITE THE WAY
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE HAPPY
WITH.
AND I THINK THIS IS -- WE'VE
FOUND A PLACE IN THE MIDDLE THAT
IS GOING TO BE EXCITING AND FUN
AND MEANINGFUL, FOR STUDENTS
THAT WILL RESONATE THEM, BE A
MIRROR FOR LATINA KIDS, BE A
WINDOW INTO THE CULTURE FOR
OTHERS BUT TEACHERS WILL BE LIKE
OH, THERE'S A SON NET IN THIS
BOOK.
THAT'S AWESOME.
>> I THINK THE WARNING IS ALWAYS
THE MOMENT YOU START WRITING FOR
THE ADULTS IF YOU'RE A
CHILDREN'S AUTHOR OR YA AUTHOR,
THE MOMENT YOU START CONSIDERING
WHAT THE ADULTS ARE GOING TO
THINK, SAY, YOU'RE A GONER.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> YOU'RE THE TED TORSO I'M
REALLY FEELING LIKE WOWSA.
>> WASN'T THAT GREAT AN EDITOR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THE TRUTH COMES OUT.
>> THIS IS THE ROUTE INTO
WRITING.
>> I WASN'T A GOOD LINE EDITOR.
I'M NOT INCREDIBLY DETAIL
ORIENTED THAT WAY.
I'M MUCH BETTER AND I TEACH
WRITING TOO SO I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ON KIND OF DIFFERENT SIDES.
I'VE BEEN A WRITING STUDENT, A
WRITING TEACHER, A WRITER, AN
EDITOR SO I SORT OF KNOW HOW ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT PLACES FEEL SO I
THINK IT GIVES ME FLUIDITY OF
WITH DRAFTS AND HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR EDITOR.
I REALLY NEVER ATTACH MYSELF TO
WHATEVER DRAFT IT IS, AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S GOING TO CHANGE.
I WANT IT TO CHANGE.
I WANT TO HEAR THAT OTHER INPUT.
I'M ACTUALLY A REALLY LINEAR
WRITER, SO I CAN GET A LITTLE
CONSTRAINED.
I ALMOST WISH I COULD JUMP
AROUND HERE AND JUMP AROUND
THERE SO I OFTEN GIVE MYSELF
SOME KIND OF LIMIT IN MY WRITING
LIKE THE DIARY FORMAT OR A POINT
OF VIEW THAT I CAN KIND OF COME
UP AGAINST AS A PROBLEM, LIKE,
HOW DO I TELL A WHOLE STORY IN A
DIARY?
AND WILL PEOPLE BE OKAY WITH ME
TAKING THE LEAP, THE MAIN
CHARACTER KIND OF MAYBE FILLING
OUT MORE OF A NARRATIVE IN THE
DIARY THAT MAYBE A 12-YEAR-OLD
WOULD ACTUALLY WRITE IN THEIR
DIARY?
AND SO I DO -- THERE WERE TIMES
WHERE I KNEW I WAS GOING TO MAKE
THAT LEAP BUT THEN THERE WERE
TIMES I REALLY HAD TO, JUST
THROUGH DRAFTS, LIKE, THAT'S TOO
MUCH.
YOU'RE REALLY WRITING SOMETHING
ELSE.
YOU'RE NOT WRITING A DIARY ENTRY
ANYMORE.
BUT I LIKE TO HAVE THOSE WALLS
TO KIND OF HIT AGAINST, AND THEN
MAKE CHOICES ABOUT THEM.
>> I FEEL LIKE I GO BACK --
[ SIMULTANEOUS SPEAKERS ]
LIKE, YOU CAN GIVE ME THE LINEAR
PARTS AND I'LL GIVE YOU MY
JUMPING-AROUND PARTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AFTER THE PANEL, WE'LL DO
THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I FEEL LIKE I GO BACK INTO MY
TEACHING LIFE.
FOR MERCY I DID THAT.
I FEEL LIKE PEOPLE ASK YOU, WHAT
DID YOU DO BEFORE YOU WERE A
WRITER AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND I FEEL LIKE EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE IN YOUR WHOLE LIFE
MAKES YOU A WRITER.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU FEEL THAT
WAY BUT I FEEL LIKE IT ALL COOKS
INTO THE PERSON WHO CREATES.
ALL RIGHT, BECAUSE WE'RE HERE
CERTAINLY IN HONOR OF "WE NEED
DIVERSE BOOKS," I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE WRITE THE NUANCED
STORIES OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IN PARTICULAR, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES FOR KIDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND ALSO BOTH THE
HARDSHIPS, THE LESS FLATTERING
PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
LIKE, HOW IS IT THAT YOU
APPROACH THAT IN YOUR WORK?
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A
BREAK, TIFFANY.
I COULD FEEL THE TERROR COMING
OFF THE WOMAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S COMING RIGHT THROUGH.
SO I'M GOING TO PUT EMILY ON THE
SPOT THIS TIME.
YOU SEE, THEY FEEL SO BAD FOR
YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I THINK IT'S REALLY A MATTER
OF BEING HONEST.
I THINK IT'S THAT I FEEL LIKE
WHEN I -- I'VE CONSIDERED MYSELF
A STORY TELLER FOR PRETTY MUCH
MOST OF MY LIFE, AND WHEN YOU
FIRST START OUT, YOUR EARLY
NOVELS, YOU'RE TRYING TO -- YOU
TRY TO WRITE THESE PERFECT
CHARACTERS WHO ARE LIKE THE
DISNEY-FIED VERSION OF MAYBE
YOURSELF OR SOME IMAGINING IN
YOUR HEAD OF, LIKE, THAT PERFECT
UNICORN HUMAN WHO DOES
EVERYTHING EXACTLY RIGHT AND
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY INTERESTING
TO READ, AND AS YOU DEVELOP AS A
WRITER, FOR ME IT WAS ABOUT
CHALLENGING MYSELF TO PUT THE
FAULTS ON THE PAGE, TO FIND
THOSE FLAWS, TO EXAMINE THEM AND
SEE HOW THEY ACTUALLY MAKE US
MORE HUMAN AND MORE INTERESTING,
AND TO PUT MISTAKES ON THE PAGE,
AND THEN KIND OF LIKE I WAS
SAYING EARLIER ABOUT HOW IT TOOK
ME SO LONG TO FIND THE CHARACTER
FOR THE ASTONISHING COLOR OF
AFTER, I HAD TO BE WILLING TO
DELVE INTO THINGS THAT WERE
DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT AND
THINK ABOUT.
AND THE UGLY PARTS OF MY
EXPERIENCES GROWING UP, NOT JUST
THE FUN THINGS, BUT, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, DEALING WITH
MICROAGGRESSIONS, AND DEALING
WITH NEVER FEELING LIKE ENOUGH,
NEVER FEELING ASIAN ENOUGH.
NEVER FEELING AMERICAN ENOUGH.
AND I THINK IT JUST REALLY
BECAME ABOUT CAPTURING THAT
TRUTH AS RESPECTFULLY AS
POSSIBLE.
AND ALSO DOING MY DUE DILIGENCE,
BECAUSE WE INEVITABLY ALL HOLD
OUR OWN BIASES, AND SO I
INTERVIEWED A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
WRITE THE ASTONISHING COLOR OF
AFTER.
I GENERALLY INTERVIEW A LOT OF
PEOPLE FOR ANYTHING I WRITE TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND THINGS FROM
ALL DIFFERENT SIDES, TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE MY BRAIN MIGHT
BE FIXATED ON SOMETHING BECAUSE
OF HOW I WAS RAISED OR WHATEVER.
>> I THINK THAT'S REALLY WISE,
ESPECIALLY, AND I KNOW THIS IS
THE INCREDIBLY THE ASTONISHING
COLOR OF AFTER IS A DIFFICULT
BEAU --
DEBUT NOVEL WHICH IS IS A
GLORIOUS ACHIEVEMENT BUT I VERY
MUCH HEAR THAT NOTION OF
HUMILITY WHEN WE APPROACH OUR
WORK AND THAT WE CAN GET THINGS
WRONG OURSELVES.
ABOUT OUR OWN COMMUNITIES EVEN.
SO IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S SUCH
A STRUGGLE RIGHT NOW IN OUR
COMMUNITY AT LARGE IN
PUBLISHING.
WHO GETS TO WRITE WHAT.
BUT WE'RE ALL BEING HELD TO THAT
STANDARD, EVEN WE ARE HOLDING
OURSELVES TO IT.
>> NO, I THINK IT WAS DANIEL
JOSÉ WHOSE COMMENT I READ A
COUPLE YEARS AGO IN TALKING
ABOUT DIVERSITY.
HE GOES I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DAY WHEN WE DON'T HAVE TO USE
THE WORD DIVERSITY ANYMORE WHEN
WORK JUST REFLECTS REALITY SO
WHEN I SET OUT TO WRITE ABOUT A
MEXICAN AMERICAN BOY IN THE
VALLEY, IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ME TO BE HONEST AND REFLECT
THE WORLD AS IT TRULY IS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A FICTIONALIZED
VERSION OF THINGS, AND AS THE
TITLE SUGGESTS THEY CALL ME GU
GUEBO.
THAT MEANS A WHITE COATED LIGHT
SKINNED MEXICAN AMERICAN AND AT
THE POINT CORE OF THE BOOK GUERO
IS COMING TO NOTICE AS THE MOST
LIGHT SKINNED PERSON IN HIS
FAMILY HE IS THE MOST PRIVILEGED
OF THE FAMILY AND PUSHING BACK
AGAINST THAT, THE WAY ANY
12-YEAR-OLD KID WOULD BECAUSE HE
ALSO FEELS PART OF A COMMUNITY,
THAT'S A COMMUNITY OF COLOR SO
EVEN THOUGH HE IS A WHITE LATINO
HE BELONGS TO A COMMUNITY OF
COLOR SO HE'S IN THIS WEIRD
LIMINAL SPACE WHERE FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN HIS SISTER TERESA WHO'S A
BASKETBALL PLAYER, HER TEAMS GET
TO GO AWAY AS PART OF THE
CHAMPIONS TO A FAR AWAY TOWN IN
ANOTHER PART OF TEXAS, THAT'S
NOT AS BROWN AS THAT SPOT.
IT HAS MANY SPOTS THAT ARE
REDDER AND WHITER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE FANS OF THE OPPOSING TEAM
START WITH A CHANT THAT WAS
RIPPED FROM THE HEADLINES OF GO
BACK BACK TO MEXICO, BUILD THAT
WALL SO SUDDENLY GUERO WHO IS
OFTEN SINGLED OUT FOR BEING
LIGHT SKINNED AND RED HAIRED AND
COLORED EYES AND FRECKLES
SUDDENLY IS DEFINITELY PART OF
THIS SOLIDARITY THAT COMES FROM
BEING ATTACKED AS TOO
COMMUNITY^, AND AT THAT MOMENT
EVEN THOUGH HE ISN'T STRICTLY
SPEAKING A CHILD OF COLOR, HE IS
A CHILD OF COLOR BECAUSE HE'S
PART OF A COMMUNITY OF COLOR AND
IT'S THAT WEIRD NEPLANTE, THAT
LIMB NALL SPACE IN BETWEEN WHERE
YOUR IDENTITY IS NEITHER ONE NOR
THE OTHER.
WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT FOR CERTAIN
PEOPLE, YOU CAN BE SEEN AS WHITE
BUT THE MINUTE YOUR LATINO
IDENTITY COMES TO THE FOREFRONT
YOU'RE NO LONGER WHITE.
I WANTED TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT,
TO SHOW THE COLORISM WITHIN HIS
OWN COMMUNITY THE WAY HE'S BOTH
TREATED BETTER AND SOMETIMES
HATED UPON FOR BEING
LIGHT-SKINNED, AND ALSO THE WAY
HIS COMMUNITY IS HAVING TO
GRAPPLE WITH WHAT'S BEING PUSHED
ON THEM IN 2019.
>> YEAH, I REALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT IDEA OF BEING IN BETWEEN,
AND NOT REALLY KNOWING WHAT
COMMUNITY YOU BELONG IN, AND
THAT'S SOMETHING I TRY TO BRING
TO ALL MY WORK, AND MY MOTHER
WAS BORN HERE AND SHE'S JEWISH
AND MY FATHER WAS BORN IN INDIA
AND HE'S HINDU AND SO I REALLY
STRUGGLED WITH THE NIGHT DIARY
BECAUSE I WAS WRITING A GIRL WHO
FIRST OF ALL WENT THROUGH THE
PARTITION IN 1947, AND I DID NOT
GO THROUGH THAT.
SO OF COURSE, I TALKED TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND I TALKED TO MY
FATHER, WHICH WAS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO TALK
TO HIM ABOUT -- I WOULD SIT DOWN
AND SAY OKAY, DAD, EVERYTHING
YOU REMEMBER, ALL THE DETAILS
YOU THINK AREN'T IMPORTANT TELL
ME, BUT THEN I TALKED TO A LOT
OF FAMILY MEMBERS AND I LISTENED
TO A LOT OF ORAL TESTIMONIES
COLLECTED THIS BOOKS AND ONLINE,
BUT I DID ASK MYSELF THE
QUESTION:  AM I SUPPOSED TO --
CAN I WRITE THIS?
IS THIS TOO MUCH OF A LEAP?
AND I COME FROM AN INTERFAITH
FAMILY, BUT MY MAIN CHARACTER IS
HINDU AND MUSLIM, BECAUSE I
WANTED HER TO ASK A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY THOSE GROUPS
WERE IN CONFLICT DURING THAT
TIME.
SO I WANTED HER TO REALLY, WHEN
HER COUNTRY IS BEING TORN APART
AND HER COMMUNITY IS BEING TORN
APART AND SHE HAS THESE MULTIPLE
IDENTITIES, WHERE DOES SHE
BELONG.
AND I CERTAINLY COULD RELATE TO
IT IN A VERY DEEPLY PERSONAL
LEVEL BECAUSE MY WHOLE LIFE, I
FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN MANAGING
MULTIPLE IDENTITIES, AND ASKING
THE QUESTION:  WHERE DO I
BELONG?
AND I'VE FOUND THAT IT REALLY
HAS BECOME MY MUSE.
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING, RICH,
COMPLICATED PLACE TO LIVE KIND
OF IN BETWEEN.
SO I PUT THAT SORT OF IN-BETWEEN
IN ALL OF MY CHARACTERS, AND ALL
OF MY WORK, BUT IT'S GOING TO
MANIFEST ITSELF DIFFERENTLY BUT
I DO LOOK FOR THAT PLACE.
WHERE CAN I TRULY, PERSONALLY,
DEEPLY CONNECT TO THIS STORY?
AND THEN IT'S GOING TO BLOSSOM
AND HAVE A LIFE OF ITS OWN AND
THEN WHEN I AM GOING MORE
OUTSIDE OF MYSELF, I SORT OF:
OKAY, I'M WRITING MORE OUTSIDE
OF MYSELF NOW.
WHAT DO I NEED?
WHAT KIND OF HELP DO I NEED?
WHAT KIND OF RESEARCH DO I NEED
TO DO?
HOW DO I SORT OF RESPECT THIS
DECISION IN THIS MOMENT IN THE
BOOK?
SO...
>> HI.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO THE CHARACTER MONDAY, SHE --
SO THE BOOK, IF SOME OF YOU
DON'T KNOW, THE BOOK TAKES PLACE
HERE IN D.C., IN SOUTHEAST D.C.,
SPECIFICALLY AND THE CHARACTER
MONDAY LIVES IN A COMMUNITY
CALLED EDBOROUGH.
IF YOU READ CONTEXT CLUES AND
YOU'RE FROM HERE, EDBOROUGH IS
ACTUALLY A COMMUNITY CALLED
BERRY FARMS.
BERRY FARMS IS OR WAS A
NOTORIOUS HOUSING PROJECT THAT
WAS AT SOME POINT SATURATED WITH
CRIME AND HAS BEEN RECENTLY SOLD
OFF TO DEVELOPERS TO BASICALLY
WIPE OUT THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY
AND REBUILD SO GENTRIFICATION ON
SPEED DIAL.
ON SPEED, I MEAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CAN'T REALLY CALL
GENTRIFICATION, BUT YOU KIND OF
CAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SO WHEN I WAS FIRST WRITING
MONDAY'S NOT COMING, THERE WAS A
LOT OF PROTESTS, A LOT OF
EXODUS, A LOT OF PEOPLE TRYING
TO STOP THIS DEVELOPMENT FROM
HAPPENING, STOPPING PEOPLE FROM
EVICTING AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
THAT'S BEEN THERE SINCE THE LAND
WAS FIRST BOUGHT FOR FREED
SLAVES SO THAT WAS LITERALLY THE
ONLY THING IN THIS BOOK THAT I
HAD CHANGED.
I ONLY CHANGED THAT.
I ONLY CHANGED THE NAME OF BERRY
FARMS TO EDBOROUGH TO BASICALLY
KIND OF NOT PUT ANYMORE
SPOTLIGHT IN ANY NEGATIVE SORT
OF SPOTLIGHT ON TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AND I DIDN'T WANT TO PAINT WHAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO DO, AS WELL,
TOO.
THAT'S SORT OF LIKE ONE OF THE
HARDER PARTS ABOUT WRITING
ABOUT, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, ROUGH
AREAS.
LIKE PROJECT HOUSES BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE HEAR THE PROJECT, THEY
IMMEDIATELY THINK LIKE THE 'HOOD
AND THAT'S NEVER BEEN MY INITIAL
THOUGHTS.
WHEN I THINK OF HOUSING PROJECTS
LIKE THAT, I THINK OF
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK OF FAMILIES.
SOME OF MY FAVORITE MEMORIES
HAVE BEEN AT MY AUNT'S HOUSE, SO
THERE IS A DELICATE BALANCE
BETWEEN PER PEP WAITING
STEREO -- PERPETUATING
STEREOTYPES AND DIVING THROUGH
THAT TRUTH AND SEEING THE COLOR
AND BEAUTY OF A COMMUNITY LIKE
THAT.
RIGHT NOW, THIS DAY, THERE ARE
ONLY 3 FAMILIES LEFT IN BERRY
FARMS, OUT OF 444, ALMOST LIKE
500 FAMILIES, WHICH IS INSANE.
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I
ALSO HAD TO GRAPPLE WITH IN
TERMS OF WHILE WRITING THIS BOOK
AS WELL, TOO, IS KNOWING THAT,
YOU KNOW, SOMEONE IS GOING TO
READ THIS BOOK NEXT YEAR AND NOT
KNOW WHAT THE HELL BERRY FARMS
EVEN WAS SO THERE WAS A VERY
MUCH A DELICATE BALANCE OF THAT.
THERE WAS A DELICATE BALANCE OF
WE WEREN'T LOUD ENOUGH WHEN ALL
THIS WAS HAPPENING.
WE DIDN'T HAVE PEOPLE SAY, NO,
THIS IS WRONG.
YOU CANNOT EVICT ALL THESE
FAMILIES AND DISPLACE THEM.
LIKE, THIS IS WRONG.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
AS A BLACK COMMUNITY, WE TEND TO
BE VERY PRIVATE ABOUT THINGS.
WE DON'T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
UGLY.
WE LIKE TO BUILD IT IN OUR OWN
WAYS, SO THAT'S SOMETHING I ALSO
WANTED TO BRING TO THE FOREFRONT
AS WELL, TOO, IS TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WHEN THINGS ARE GOING
BAD WE ARE DEALING WITH A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND WE
CAN'T JUST ERASE IT BY, YOU
KNOW, PRAYING ABOUT IT.
WE SHOULD TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT
IT.
WE SHOULD RAISE OUR VOICES ABOUT
IT SO I THINK THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT I -- AND I KNEW THAT I
WOULD PROBABLY GET A LOT OF
FLACK FOR IT IN A WAY BECAUSE I
WAS SORT OF EXPOSING A LITTLE OF
THE DIRTY LAUNDRY AT THE SAME
TIME BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT AND SO I'LL TAKE THE
HITS IF I KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITY HEAL, AND
SORT OF ERASE THE STEREOTYPES OF
WHAT HOUSING PROJECTS COULD BE
LIKE, AS WELL, TOO.
>> I FEEL THE WEIGHT OF THE
DIRTY LAUNDRY THINGS TOO WHEN
I'M WRITING ABOUT MACHISMO OR
FAMILY VIOLENCE, THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
I FEEL LIKE -- BUT I'M WITH
EMILY AND WITH ALL OF YOU.
JUST LIKE THE PUSH OF THE TRUTH
FEELS LIKE MORE URGENT TO ME.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT WRITING
REALLY HARD EMOTIONAL TRUTHS FOR
CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THAT TAKES A LOT OF
THINKING.
IT TAKES A LOT OF THINKING, AND
IT TAKES A LOT OF CONSIDERATION
OF WHO THE CHILDREN ARE, HOW OLD
THEY ARE, ALL OF THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HOW DO YOU APPROACH THAT?
BECAUSE I MEAN THINK OF THE
SUBJECTS THAT WE HAVE HERE,
RIGHT?
WE HAVE ADULTS MURDERING EACH
OTHER.
WE HAVE A MOM'S SUICIDE.
WE HAVE THE LOSS OF A FRIEND.
WE HAVE GRAPPLING WITH, LIKE,
DEEP IDENTITY:  WHO AM I IF I
DON'T LOOK LIKE MY FAMILY?
WHO AM I?
SO HOW DO WE WRITE THESE PAINFUL
THINGS?
WHAT ARE THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS
YOU ASK YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE
GOING TO WRITE SOMETHING THAT'S
VIOLENT, THAT'S HARD, THAT'S
TRUE?
>> I TYPICALLY -- SO I'M KIND OF
KNOWN FOR GUT-PUNCHING PEOPLE
WITH MY STORIES, TO PUT IT VERY
LIGHTLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YES.
>> BECAUSE I ALWAYS -- I FEEL
THAT WE GROSSLY UNDERESTIMATE
WHAT KIDS CAN HANDLE AS FAR AS
PAIN, AS FAR AS WHAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO ABSORB.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, I
FEEL LIKE IT'S MORE URGENT FOR
US TO DO THAT.
WHEN I THINK OF WRITING STORIES,
I WANT TO WRITE RAW STORIES.
I WANT TO WRITE STORIES THAT
REALLY STICK WITH YOU.
YOU ALWAYS REMEMBER THE FIRST
TIME YOU GOT HIT.
I MEAN, I DO.
SO I FEEL LIKE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU REMEMBER THAT STORY.
YOU DON'T WANT THAT STORY TO
REALLY LEAVE THE PERSON'S HEAD.
I WANT MY STORIES TO BE RAW.
I WANT THE PLOT TWISTS TO BE
FOREVER IN MY BOOKS SO THAT KIDS
REMEMBER THOSE LESSONS SO IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS WHEN KIDS ARE IN
VOTING BOOTHS AND THEY HAVE TO
VOTE ON A PROPOSITION THAT'S
GOING TO ERASE AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY, I WANT THEM TO
REMEMBER MONDAY AND BERRY FARMS
AND EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED IN
MONDAY'S NOT COMING SO I
PERSONALLY FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT
THAT I DON'T CARE ABOUT HOW
EMOTIONALLY TRIGGERING THE BOOK
COULD BE, BUT I ALSO FEEL LIKE
THERE'S AN URGENCY TO FIX OTHER
THINGS THAT MATTER MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
>> YEAH, TOTALLY.
I AGREE, I THINK IT'S REALLY
DANGEROUS TO START OFF GOING:
OH, I NEED TO PROTECT THE KIDS,
BECAUSE THE KIDS ARE GRAPPLING
WITH STUFF.
I MEAN, I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS
THAT AGE AND THE KINDS OF STUFF
I HAD TO GRAPPLE WITH AND I
REMEMBER WHAT IT WAS LIKE FOR MY
DAD TO ABANDON US AND THE
DEVASTATION YOU FEEL AFTER THAT
SO I DELIBERATELY TRY TO TAP
INTO THE THINGS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WRITING FOR
UPPER MIDDLE GRADE AND YA, IF
WRITING THE BOOK, IF I DO NOT
BREAK DOWN WEEPING SEVERAL TIMES
WRITING THE BOOK, THEN I'M NOT
DOING MY JOB BECAUSE I NEED TO
TAP INTO SOMETHING THAT'S SO RAW
AND VIBRANT THAT I CAN PUT IT
ACROSS.
AND THEN YOU LAYER A LITTLE BIT
OF PROTECTION FOR THE KIDS SO
THEY'RE NOT BEING SLAMMED WITH
IT LIKE SO BRUTALLY BUT YOU WANT
THAT EMOTION TO BE THERE BECAUSE
THEY CAN TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
THEY KNOW WHEN YOU'RE JUST
WRITING SOMETHING SUPERFICIALLY
TO GET A PAYCHECK AND GET ON THE
BEST SELLER LIST OR WHEN YOU'RE
WRITING SOMETHING THAT IS
MEANINGFUL AND YOU TRY AND
TRANSMIT YOUR OWN DEEPLY FELT
TRAUMA, EMOTION, OR JOY OR
WHATEVER THE EMOTION HAPPENS TO
BE, RIGHT, TO THEM.
AND WHEN PEOPLE -- I REMEMBER
ANNA MARIAN NO ADDING ME ON
TWITTER BECAUSE SHE WAS
WRAPPING UP THE BOOK AND SHE
LOVED IT AND SHE READ THE BOOK
ABOUT THE BOY'S DOG, AND SHE WAS
LIKE WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS TO
ME?
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT BECAUSE EVERY CHILD
EXPERIENCES THE DEATH OF A PET,
AND A LOT OF TIMES FOR KIDS,
IT'S THE VERY FIRST TIME THAT
THEY HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT
AND I REMEMBER MY DOG DYING WHEN
I WAS 7, AND HOW I WAS JUST -- I
WAS SO HURT AND SO, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE BEING FACED WITH
THIS DARKNESS THAT EXISTS ALL
AROUND YOU, AND YOU'RE NOT READY
FOR IT BUT THE WORLD THRUSTS IT
ON YOU, AND I THINK IT'S KIND OF
LIKE INCUMBENT UPON US TO BE THE
PERSON THAT HOLDS THE KID'S HAND
AND SAY LOOK, THERE'S DARKNESS.
YOU NEED TO SEE IT BUT I'M GOING
TO WALK WITH YOU AND WE'RE GOING
TO LOOK AT IT TOGETHER SO THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE
IN THIS.
IF WE COULD PUT THAT ACROSS I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> HOW ABOUT WITH YOURS, EMILY?
IT DEALS WITH A PARENTAL
SUICIDE, AND I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE WORD TRIGGERS, I I'M
THINKING OF ALL OF THOSE THINGS
THINGS^.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING ABOUT
WHEN YOU WERE WRITING THOSE
SCENES AND THAT REALITY?
WERE YOU THINKING ABOUT THE
READER?
WERE YOU COMPLETELY IMMERSED IN
STORY?
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
>> IT'S TRICKY, BECAUSE I, WHEN
I SAT DOWN IN FRONT OF THE YET
AGAIN BLANK SCREEN, JANUARY 2,
2015, LITERALLY REWRITING THE
BOOK FROM SCRATCH AGAIN, I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS SETTING
OUT TO WRITE.
AND THE OPENING PAGES OF THE
BOOK POURED OUT OF ME.
I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HOW IT WAS
KIND OF LIKE A FUGUE STATE AND I
THINK I'VE HAMMERED HOME THE
POINT THAT I REWRITE THINGS OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THOSE OPENING PAGES ARE THE ONLY
PAGES IN THE BOOK THAT HAVE BEEN
SO PRESERVED SINCE THAT FIRST
DRAFT AND IN THE OPENING, IT
STARTS WITH LI, YOU KNOW, SEEING
THAT HER MOTHER HAS DIED BY
SUICIDE, AND I HONESTLY DID NOT
SET OUT TO WRITE A BOOK ABOUT
SUICIDE OR A BOOK ABOUT
DEPRESSION, BUT I HAD LOST MY
AUNT TO SUICIDE THE YEAR BEFORE,
AND I COULDN'T STOP THINKING
ABOUT IT.
AND KIND OF GOING BACK TO WHAT
YOU WERE SAYING WITH, LIKE, KIDS
DEALING WITH GRIEF, THE FIRST
TIME I LOST SOMEONE, I WAS 8
YEARS OLD.
MY GRANDFATHER, MY PATERNAL
GRANDFATHER PASSED AWAY 8 DAYS
BEFORE MY BIRTHDAY AND MY
PARENTS DIDN'T TELL ME FOR A
WHOLE MONTH BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO RUIN MY BIRTHDAY.
AND THEN THEY ALSO SAID, BUT YOU
DON'T NEED GO UPSET WHEN THEY
FINALLY TOLD ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS IS A PATTERN IN MY FAMILY.
THEY DEAL WITH DEATH IN THIS
REALLY WEIRD WAY.
WHEN MY CHILDHOOD DOG PASSED
AWAY WHICH WAS JUST A HANDFUL OF
YEARS AGO, MY PARENTS ALSO,
LIKE, DIDN'T TELL ME UNTIL OUR,
LIKE, NIGHTLY PHONE CALL BECAUSE
I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
CALLS MY PARENTS EVERY DAY SO AT
NIGHT I CALL THEM AND THEY'RE
OH, LIKE, THIS -- I'M LIKE ONE
OF THOSE CO-DEPENDENT ONLY
CHILDREN, WHO, LIKE -- ANYWAY,
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SO, LIKE, THEY DIDN'T TELL
ME UNTIL NIGHTTIME THAT, LIKE,
THEY HAD TAKEN MY DOG TO BE PUT
DOWN THAT MORNING.
AND WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT MY
AUNT DIED IT WAS AGAIN, LIKE, AT
MIDNIGHT, I WAS LIKE OH, CRAP, I
GOTTA CALL MY PARENTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GOING TO BED
SOON AND MY DAD LET ME GO
THROUGH MY WHOLE RAMBLE OF ALL
THE MUNDANE THINGS HAPPENING IN
MY LIFE BEFORE HE WAS LIKE:
THERE'S SOME SAD NEWS.
YOUR AUNT PASSED THIS MORNING.
AND I WAS LIKE WTF!
LIKE, HOW WAS THIS FAMILY SO
UNHEALTHY ABOUT GRIEF?
AND THEN THEY DID THE WHOLE SONG
AND DANCE OF LIKE, YOU DON'T
NEED TO BURDEN YOURSELF.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
OF ALL MY EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS, SHE'S THE ONE THAT I
ACTUALLY FELT THE CLOSEST TO.
AND SO IT WAS THIS, FOR ME, WHEN
I WAS WRITING, SORRY, THIS IS A
LONG-WINDED ANSWER.
WHEN I WAS WRITING IT WAS LIKE I
WAS TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH A LOT
OF THINGS.
I WAS TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH ALL
THESE THINGS THAT I'D SORT OF
SHELFED.
IT TOOK ME UNTIL I GOT TO
COLLEGE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
WAY I HAD GROANED UP WAS
ABNORMAL.
THAT THE WAY DEPRESSION TAKES UP
SO MUCH SPACE IN A HOUSE, THAT
THE THINGS THAT WERE MAY
CONCERNS AS I WAS GROWING UP
WERE NOT THE CONCERNS OF MANY
OTHER KIDS AROUND ME.
AND SO WHEN I WAS WRITING THE
BOOK, THE FIRST DRAFT WAS REALLY
ME WRITING PURELY FOR MYSELF,
AND IT WAS AS I DELVED INTO --
IT TOOK ME UNTIL DRAFT 3 TO BE
LIKE OH, I GOTTA LOOK DEPRESSION
HEAD-ON.
I'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT SUICIDE.
I'VE GOT TO TALK ABOUT HOW IT
AFFECTS NOT JUST ONE PERSON, BUT
THE WHOLE FAMILY.
AND THEN IT BECAME THIS THING
WHERE I HAD TO CAREFULLY CARVE
AWAY AND SAY WHAT THINGS DO I
WANT TO SHOW ON THE PAGE?
WHAT THINGS DO I WANT TO PROTECT
READERS FROM?
ESPECIALLY READERS WHO ARE
FELLOW SUICIDE LOSS SURVIVORS.
I'M FULLY AWARE THAT FOR SOME
PEOPLE IT WILL BE TOO TRIGGERING
OF A BOOK TO READ, AND OTHERS,
MANY SUICIDE LOSS SURVIVORS HAVE
REACHED OUT TO ME TO SAY THAT
THEY REALLY NEEDED A BOOK LIKE
THAT AND SO I THINK IT'S -- IT
IS A REALLY TRICKY THING TO
NAVIGATE, TO FIGURE OUT, LIKE,
WHAT KIND OF LANGUAGE MIGHT BE
POETIC BUT IS ACTUALLY DAMAGING,
AND WHAT KIND OF THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY IMPORTANT TO EXPLORE TO
ALLOW FOR THAT SAFE SPACE.
WHEN I WASN'T GIVEN THE CHANCE
TO GRIEVE FOR MY GRANDFATHER
WHEN I WAS 8, I FOUND MY SOLACE
IN BOOKS LIKE I READ WHERE THE
REDFERN GROWS AND SOBBED MY EYES
OUT BECAUSE IT WAS A SAFE SPACE
TO GRIEVE OVER THE DEATH OF
THESE WONDERFUL DOGS AND I
NEEDED TO HAVE THAT SPACE SO I
HOPE THAT I CAN OFFER A SAFE
SPACE TO SOMEBODY WHO NEEDS
SOMETHING FICTIONAL TO CRY ABOUT
IN ORDER TO WORK OUT THEIR REAL
REAL-LIFE FEELINGS.
>> AND, VEERA --
[ APPLAUSE ]
I'M THINKING, ALSO, VEERA, THAT
YOU PEELED BACK A WINDOW INTO
ADULTS -- THE VIOLENCE THAT
ADULTS PERPETRATE ON EACH OTHER
IN THE FULL SIGHT OF CHILDREN.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
THAT WAS VERY DIFFICULT, AND,
YOU KNOW, I WOULD HEAR STORIES
AND LOOK AT PICTURES TAKEN OF
THE TIME.
I MEAN, THERE WERE TRAINS THAT
WERE INTERCEPTED GOING IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS WHERE THEY WOULD
BE -- TRAINS WOULD BE STOPPED BY
RIDERS AND EVERYBODY WOULD GET
OUT OR GET IN, AND THERE WOULD
BE THIS HORRIBLE SIGHT, AND THEN
THERE WOULD BE -- TRAINS WOULD
PULL UP IN STATIONS FILLED WITH
CORPSES DURING THE PARTITION, SO
IF YOU TALK TO ANYBODY WHO'S
BEEN THROUGH THIS TIME, AND YOU
MENTION THE TRAINS, THAT'S --
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT "THE
TRAINS" MEAN.
YOU JUST HAVE TO SAY "THE
TRAINS."
MY FATHER'S FAMILY GOT ON A
TRAIN AND MADE IT SAFELY OVER
THE BORDER, BUT SO MANY PEOPLE
DID NOT.
SO I HAD TO FIGURE OUT HOW I
WRITE SOMETHING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO SEE THE TRUTH OF THIS
HISTORY.
I MEAN, IT'S A LIVING HISTORY
STILL.
MY FATHER'S IN HIS 80s AND
MOST PEOPLE -- AND HE WAS 9 WHEN
HE WENT THROUGH THIS, SO MOST
PEOPLE WHO WENT THROUGH THE
PARTITION ARE IN THEIR 80s AND
90s, AND OLDER, AND THEN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE THESE PEOPLE
ALIVE TO TELL THEIR STORIES
ANYMORE SO I THINK PEOPLE OF MY
GENERATION FROM PARTITION
SURVIVORS REALLY FEEL THIS
URGENCY.
I DEFINITELY FELT AN URGENCY TO
CAPTURE THIS HISTORY IN THE WAY
THAT I COULD AND PEOPLE ARE
DOING IT IN DIFFERENT WAYS, JUST
TO MAKE SURE TO CAPTURE IT.
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE HISTORY IS
SO BLOODY AND SO UNIMAGINABLE
THAT I WANTED TO HAVE SOME OF
THAT TRUTH IN THE STORY, BUT I'M
ALSO A PARENT, AND I FELT LIKE
WHAT CAN KIDS HANDLE?
AND I THINK THAT THEY CAN HANDLE
A LOT, BUT I ALSO DIDN'T WANT TO
SORT OF INTERRUPT THE EXPERIENCE
OF LEARNING ABOUT THIS HISTORY,
MAKING IT TOO TRAUMATIC, BECAUSE
THE RAW HISTORY IS -- YOU CAN'T
EVEN PROCESS IT.
AND I WOULD SIT WITH TEARS
STREAMING DOWN MY FACE LOOKING
AT PICTURES, OR FEEL SICK
SOMETIMES, BUT THEN I WOULD JUST
TAKE THAT FEELING AND SEE:  HOW
CAN I KIND OF MATCH ALL THOSE
THINGS:  THE TRUTH OF THE
CHARACTER, THE TRUTH OF THEIR
STORY.
PULLING IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
STORIES THAT I RESEARCHED, AND
THERE WAS SOME PROTECTION.
I WAS PROTECTING THE YOUNG
READER AT CERTAIN TIMES.
>> AND I THINK YOURS IS A MIDDLE
GRADE NOVEL AS OPPOSED TO YA.
I WRITE ACROSS THOSE AGE GROUPS
TOO, AND THERE ARE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT CONSIDERATIONS FOR
EACH ONE.
I THINK SOMEONE AT 17 ISN'T
SOMEONE AT 11, RIGHT?
SO WE MODULATE.
WE HAVE TO MODULATE THAT.
SO BECAUSE I HAVE CONSIDERATION
FOR YOU FOLKS I'M NOT GOING TO
LEAVE YOU ON THIS SAD PLACE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO THIS IS A JOYOUS DAY,
FRIENDS, RIGHT?
SO I THINK NOW WE TALK FUN
THINGS.
SO I AM JUST INTERESTED IN LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT WHAT
A CAREER THIS IS.
RIGHT?
WHAT A JOURNEY!
I HAD NO IDEA WHENTYTY -- WHEN I
DECIDED I WANTED TO BE A WRITER
OR TRY, I REALLY, REALLY HAD NO
IDEA.
SO I'M CURIOUS, WHAT HAS
SURPRISED YOU ABOUT BEING AN
AUTHOR?
WHAT HAS DELIGHTED YOU?
AND WHAT HAS BEEN MAYBE SHOCKING
IN NOT SUCH A GOOD WAY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THIS COULD BE A FREE-FOR-ALL.
WE HAVE ACTIONS TO GRIND RIGHT
HERE.
NO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHAT HAS DELIGHTED YOU?
WHAT HAS SURPRISED YOU?
>> SO WHEN I WAS GROWING UP I
HONESTLY THOUGHT THAT WRITERS
WERE VERY SOLO CAREERS.
YOU'RE BY YOURSELF SO I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN SO SURPRISED BY
HOW MANY PEOPLE I'VE ACTUALLY
HAD TO TALK TO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LIKE THIS!
FOR THOSE WHO REALLY KNOW ME I'M
ACTUALLY STILL, LIKE, QUITE SHY
SO THIS IS, LIKE, MY WORST
NIGHTMARE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT, LIKE, YEAH, I'M ACTUALLY
REALLY SURPRISED BUT ALSO
DELIGHTED BY THE FACT THAT I DO
GET TO GO AND TOUR AROUND AND GO
DO SCHOOL VISITS AND TALKS TO
KIDS.
AND KIDS, THEY'LL KEEP YOU
HUMBLE.
>> YEAH!
>> BLESS THEIR HEARTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN LIKE, I'M
SO SURPRISED BY HOW MANY PEOPLE
I GOT TO TALK TO, AND HOW MANY
KIDS I GOT TO TALK TO.
HOW MANY PRISONS I'VE GOTTEN A
CHANCE TO VISIT AND THE YOUNG
MEN IN THERE AND TALKING TO THEM
AND HEARING THEIR STORIES.
BECAUSE I HONESTLY, BY NOW, I
REALLY THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO BE
LIKE THE OLD WOMAN BY THE SEA.
I REALLY WAS JUST LIKE, I HAD MY
SHACK READY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DIDN'T THINK I HAD TO TALK TO
ANYONE.
I DEFINITELY DIDN'T THINK I'D
HAVE TO BE ON TWITTER AND HAVE
TO INTERACT.
I DON'T REALLY DO PEOPLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO THAT HAS BEEN, LIKE, YOU KNOW
A JOYOUS SURPRISE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WHAT SURPRISED YOU, MS.
MS. DEBUT?
TELL ME.
>> I'M PERPETUALLY SURPRISED ALL
OVER AGAIN WHEN I'M SIGNING
BOOKS AND AN ASIAN-AMERICAN
READER COMES UP TO ME AND SAYS:
I DIDN'T REALIZE WE COULD DO
THIS, AND SAYS THAT, LIKE,
YOU'RE THE FIRST ASIAN AUTHOR
I'VE EVER MET.
AND EVERY SINGLE TIME I'M LIKE
BOWLED OVER BY THAT, AND LIKE I
DID A SCHOOL VISIT AT MY OWN
MIDDLE SCHOOL A FEW MONTHS AGO
AND THERE WAS THIS ONE
ASIAN-AMERICAN GIRL WHO CAME UP
TO ME AND WAS IN TEARS.
I'M LIKE, ARE YOU OKAY?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
AND SHE WAS LIKE:  YOU'RE, LIKE,
A WRITER!
YOU'RE, LIKE, THE REAL DEAL.
I WAS LIKE, WHOA!
THIS IS LIKE A LOT, YEAH.
AND THAT'S BEEN LIKE REALLY
AMAZING AND ALSO REALLY
DEPRESSING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YEAH, AND THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING THING THAT
THERE ARE SURPRISES THAT ARE
BOTH REALLY JOYOUS AND REALLY
SAD.
I WAS SAD TO FIND OUT HOW FEW
BOOKS WERE WRITTEN BY OR ABOUT
PEOPLE OF COLOR, AND I MEAN
WE'RE IMPROVING EVERY YEAR, BUT
THAT'S A REALLY SAD REALITY WHEN
YOU LOOK OUT AT OUR COUNTRY AND
SEE WHO'S HERE, AND THE VIBRANCY
OF THE COUNTRY.
>> I CO-SIGN EVERYTHING TIFFANY
AND EMILY JUST SAID.
THE OTHER THING THAT REALLY
SURPRISES ME THOUGH THAT I GUESS
I WASN'T REALLY PREPARED FOR IS
HOW INCREDIBLY REWARDING AND
EDIFYING IT WOULD BE TO BE PART
OF A COMMUNITY OF WRITERS, THAT
THE LATINX CAUCUS, THE LARGER
COMMUNITY OF WRITERS OF COLOR,
THEY WELCOME YOU WITH OPEN ARMS.
THEY MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE JUST
ANOTHER SIBLING AND PART OF THIS
REALLY, REALLY BIG FAMILY, AND
THEY'RE PEOPLE YOU CAN CO- CAN
COMMISERATE ABOUT THESE REALLY
THINGS AND TO HAVE THAT NETWORK
AND HAVE EACH OTHER'S BACKS AND
TO GO INTO, BE ON A PANEL OR
WHATEVER AND SEE ONE OF YOUR
FRIENDS IN THE AUDIENCE AND KNOW
THERE'S THAT SOLIDARITY.
IT'S SOMETHING REALLY SPECIAL.
>> I FOUND THAT JUST BEING
WELCOMED IN SO MANY WRITING
COMMUNITIES, AND PARTICULARLY
WITH THIS BOOK IN THE SOUTH
ASIAN WRITING COMMUNITY, I THINK
THAT THAT HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
JOYOUS FOR ME, AND IN SOME WAYS
HEALING, BECAUSE I WASN'T SURE
IF I WAS, LIKE, ALLOWED, BEING
HALF INDIAN.
AND SO THAT HALFNESS HAS BEEN
HARD FOR ME TO FIGURE OUT, AND
THEN I'VE JUST BEEN SO WELCOMED
AND VALIDATED AND I JUST FEEL
LIKE IT'S OKAY TO BE ME, AND SO
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY SURPRISING
AND WONDERFUL.
>> I'VE ENJOYED THE HONOR OF
JUST BEING WITH PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THEIR IMAGINATION.
THERE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIFT IN THAT
THAT, AND WORKING WITH ADULTS
WHO STILL LIVE IN THE WORLD OF
PRETEND AND WHAT-IF, AND WHO CAN
STILL REMEMBER SO CLEARLY WHAT
IT IS TO BE A CHILD.
I LOVE THAT.
AND I'M GETTING READY TO WRAP UP
AND WHAT I WANT TO SAY TO ALL OF
YOU IS THIS --
IT HAS BEEN SUCH AN HONOR TO BE
ON THIS STAGE WITH YOU, AND I'M
SO EXCITED TO BE WRITING BOOKS
IN THE TIME OF TIFFANY AND EMILY
AND DAVID AND VEERA, AND I JUST
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT ELSE YOU
HAVE INSIDE OF YOU.
SO IF THERE ARE -- I THINK WE'RE
READY?
OH, IF WE HAVE QUESTIONS, WE CAN
ASK THEM NOW.
I SEE ONE OVER HERE.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO STAND UP
AND GIVE US YOUR QUESTION?
GO AHEAD.
MM-HMM.
[ INAUDIBLE COMMENT ]
HOW DID YOU FEEL WHEN YOU WERE
WRITING THE BOOK?
ANYONE WANT TO FIELD THAT ONE?
>> MY BOOK IS A SAD BOOK, SO I
MEAN -- I MEAN, I CRIED ON EVERY
DRAFT.
I'M ALSO JUST LIKE PRONE TO
CRYING.
>> I WAS REAL EXCITED BECAUSE
THIS IS -- YOU KNOW, OTHER THAN
LIKE YOU KNOW MESSING WITH
PEOPLE'S HEADS BECAUSE THAT'S
EXCITING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK I WAS REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE THIS BOOK TAKES PLACE
HERE IN D.C., WHICH IS VERY MUCH
MY SECOND HOME AND SO I WAS
EXCITED TO BRING A LOT OF D.C.
SUBCULTURE TO THE PAGE.
LIKE I WAS TALKING TO, LIKE, I
WAS TALKING ABOUT GO-GO MUSIC
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
AND I WAS, I GOT A CHANCE TO USE
D.C. SLANG.
I GOT TO CALL PEOPLE BAMAS, I
WAS TALKING ABOUT CHICKEN MAMBU
SAUCE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE HERE FROM
SOUTHEAST D.C.?
ALL RIGHT!
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY I WAS
WRITING FOR THEM.
I WAS WRITING FOR KIDS TO SEE
THEMSELVES ON THE PAGE, TOO.
EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT FROM HERE I
LOVE IT AS WELL TOO.
SO THAT WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS HOW I FELT.
IT WAS AMAZING.
>> BUT YOU WENT TO SCHOOL HERE.
>> YOU WENT TO COLLEGE.
>> YEAH, SO I'M TECHNICALLY --
I'M SORT OF FROM HERE.
>> WHERE ARE YOU FROM BEFORE
HERE?
>> BROOKLYN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> EVERYBODY WANTS TO OWN
BROOKLYN.
I'M A QUEENS GIRL AND WE DON'T
GET ENOUGH LOVE.
I'M JUST SAYIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU SEE?
>> I TRIED TO REEL IT IN, BUT IT
WAS TOO LATE.
>> OTHER QUESTIONS, OTHER
QUESTIONS.
ANYONE ELSE?
YES?
STAND UP AND GIVE IT.
>> OH, THIS GROUP IS LIVELY.
[ INAUDIBLE COMMENT ]
>> HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THE
ENDING OF YOUR BOOK.
>> HOW DO WE END BOOKS?
THAT'S A TOUGHY.
>> I JUST STOP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LIKE, THAT'S ENOUGH OF THIS.
QUICK EPIGRAPH, REAL SHORT POEM,
BOOM, LET'S GO.
>> LET ME ASK YOU BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO PIGGYBACK ON YOURS.
IS THE ENDING WE READ IN THE
ACTUAL BOOK, IS THAT YOUR FIRST
ENDING?
IS THAT HOW YOU ORIGINALLY ENDED
IT.
>> NO.
>> ENDINGS ARE SO HARD.
THE FIRST ONE TENDS TO BE THAT
SORT OF WRAP IT UP AND STOP, I
JUST HAVE TO STOP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND YOU KIND OF GO BACK AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
IT'S SO HARD TO GET RIGHT.
I REALLY STRUGGLE WITH ENDINGS.
>> MEANWHILE, TIFFANY IS LIKE
NICE, RENT.
>> IT'S TERRIBLE UP HERE.
>> YOU NEED A CHARACTER NAMED
EMILY.
>> SO BOTH OF MY BOOKS ARE
LOOSELY INSPIRED BY REAL CASES
SO MONDAY'S NOT COMING WAS
INSPIRED BY TWO REAL CASES OF
HAPPENINGS THAT HAPPENED, AND
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE FROM D.C.
YOU REMEMBER THE BENITA JACKS
CASE.
THAT WAS VERY MUCH SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED HERE.
ONLY A DECADE AGO, SO THE
ENDINGS ARE SORT OF ALREADY -- I
ALREADY HAVE THEM.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE LIKE, HOW DO YOU
COME UP WITH THESE CRAZY BOOKS?
I'M LIKE ACTUALLY, HERE'S THE
ARTICLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M NOT MAKING UP ANYTHING.
SO I GUESS THAT'S WHERE I SORT
OF COME TO THE CONCLUSIONS OF
LIKE THE ENDINGS OF BOOKS IS
LIKE USING THE REAL CASES, AND
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE
SENSE OF THE TRAUMA, AND MAKE
SENSE OF THE TRAGEDY, BY LAYING
OUT AS MUCH CAUSES AND EFFECTS
OF HOW THINGS HAPPENED.
BECAUSE I WANT YOU GUYS
PARTICULARLY TO REALIZE, LIKE,
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW -- NO ONE
IS BORN BAD.
EVERYONE IS GROWN AND DEVELOPED
OUT OF SOMETHING, AND I WANT YOU
TO SEE ALL THOSE ELEMENTS.
I WANT YOU TO SEE HOW
GENTRIFICATION, HOW THE CRACK
EPIDEMIC, HOW POVERTY, HOW
EVERYTHING ACTUALLY AFFECTS HOW
SOMEONE GROWS AND THEIR CHOICES
THAT THEY EVENTUALLY MAKE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> VERY GOOD.
>> ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
>> THERE'S ONE, FAR IN THE BACK.
>> IN THE MIDDLE?
>> BY THE CAMERA.
>> OH, YES.
PICK THE MIC UP?
>> MY QUESTION IS DIRECTED
TOWARDS TIFFANY.
IS THERE A SPECIFIC REASON WHY
YOU CHOSE TO TALK ABOUT MONDAY
BEING A CHILD WHO WAS BEING
ABUSED BY HER FAMILY?
>> BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED TO THE GIRLS IN THE
INSPIRED STORY SO THAT WAS THE
REAL REASON WHY I CHOSE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT TRAUMA, AND TALK
ABOUT WHERE THAT TRAUMA WAS
ROOTED FROM, AS WELL, TOO.
>> ONE MORE?
>> THERE'S SOME GIRLS WAY IN THE
BACK BY THE CAMERA.
>> WAY IN THE BACK IN THE WHITE.
>> I ACTUALLY EVENTUALLY WILL
NEED GLASSES.
THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS.
>> HI.
I WAS WONDERING, FOR MISS EMILY,
HOW DID YOUR FAMILY REACT TO YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE TRAUMA THAT
YOU WENT THROUGH WHEN YOU WERE
YOUNGER IN THE BOOK?
HOW DID THEY REACT TO YOUR
BOOKS, IN GENERAL?
>> MY PARENTS HAVEN'T FINISHED
READING IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT IS HILARIOUS.
>> BUT I DID SIT DOWN WITH THEM
WHEN WE SOLD THE BOOK, TO BE
LIKE THIS, IS COMING OUT.
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I SORT OF FEEL LIKE MY FAMILY IS
MAYBE A LITTLE -- I'M LIKE, ARE
THEY WATCHING THIS?
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH, WE ARE LIVE STREAMING.
I THINK MY FAMILY IS PROBABLY A
LITTLE UNPREPARED FOR HOW
HONESTY LIKE TO BE IN MY WORK.
LIKE, ONE TIME I WROTE A SHORT
STORY ABOUT SOMEONE WITH BAD
BREATH AND MY MOM WAS LIKE,
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THINK YOU
HAVE BAD BREATH.
>> IF SHE ONLY KNEW THAT THAT'S
THE SMALLEST PROBLEM.
>> SO WHAT I DID, I DID FEEL I
WANTED TO BE RESPECTFUL SO I DID
REACH OUT TO MY COUSINS AND I
DID REACH OUT TO MY PARENTS, AND
SAY:  THIS IS SOMETHING I'M
WRITING ABOUT.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU FEEL VERY
TRAPPED BY THE STIGMA, AND YOU
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S DEPRESSION IN OUR
FAMILY, AND YOU DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO SEE US IN THAT LIGHT
THAT YOU CAST UPON THIS ENTIRE
TOPIC.
AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
AND SO IT STARTED WITH THIS LIKE
GROWING UP, MY PARENTS WERE
ALWAYS LIKE, DON'T LET PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THERE'S DEPRESSION IN
YOUR FAMILY BECAUSE THEY'LL LOOK
AT YOU DIFFERENTLY, AND I ALWAYS
REALLY PUSHED AGAINST THAT.
I ALWAYS FELT LIKE IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEEDED TO --
LIKE, DEPRESSION, ANY MENTAL
ILLNESS, IT'S A HEALTH PROBLEM.
LIKE, SOMEBODY WHO HAS DIABETES
NEEDS INSULIN.
MAYBE SOMEONE WHO HAS DEPRESSION
NEEDS MORE SEROTONIN SO WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS THE
SAME WAY WE CAN TALK ABOUT OTHER
HEALTH ISSUES SO THAT THE STIGMA
DOESN'T CAUSE PEOPLE TO DO MORE
DAMAGE TO THEMSELVES, TO FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE TO HIDE, AND THEY
CAN'T LIVE OUT THERE FREELY, AND
SO I'VE ALWAYS BEEN MORE VOCAL
THAN MY FAMILY WANTED ME TO BE
ABOUT IT, AND THEN WHEN I WROTE
THIS BOOK, I HAD TO SORT OF SIT
MY PARENTS DOWN AND BE LIKE:
HOW MUCH ARE YOU WILLING TO LET
ME TALK ABOUT?
AND THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
AMAZING GIFTS OF THIS JOURNEY,
IS THAT MY PARENTS HAVE STARTED
TO OPEN UP MORE ABOUT IT.
YEAH.
AND MY MOM HAS SAID TO ME, TOO,
THAT ONE DAY, I ALSO WANT TO
WRITE ABOUT OUR FAMILY.
IT'S A GOAL.
MY MOM IS ALSO A WRITER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WONDERFUL.
>> SO THAT'S BEEN -- MY MOM IS A
CREATIVE NON-FICTION WRITER SO
FEEL LIKE THROUGH HER LENS IT
WOULD BE REALLY ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND SO, YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION.
IT'S COMPLICATED.
I'LL REPORT BACK TO YOU WHEN
THEY ACTUALLY FINISH THE BOOK.
>> WE WANT THE TRANSCRIPT OF THE
CALL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, IF WE CAN GIVE THESE
WONDERFUL AUTHORS A HAND.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WHEN WE SELECTED THE TOPIC,
READ, DISCOVER, GROW, WE HAD NO
IDEA HOW MUCH WE WOULD GROW IN
SUCH A SHORT TIME.
THANK YOU AGAIN, ALL OF YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I TOOK SO MANY NOTES, THE
NUANCED STORIES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, THE CHALLENGES OF
PERPETUATING STEREOTYPES, OR
TELLING THE TRUTH.
I JUST COULD GO ON FOREVER AND I
THINK THIS HAS JUST BEEN SUCH A
WONDERFUL SYMPOSIUM, AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FOR PARTNERING WITH
US, AND BRINGING YOUR VOICES,
YOUR WONDERFUL VOICE, AND ALSO
BRINGING IN ADULTS, STUDENTS,
EDUCATORS, LIBRARIANS, AND YOU
GUYS, ESPECIALLY THE STUDENTS
ASK SUCH WONDERFUL QUESTIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
SHORT BREAK, AND I MEAN SHORT.
15 MINUTES.
THERE IS COFFEE AND LIGHT
REFRESHMENTS IN THE WHITTALL
PAVILION NEXT DOOR, EXCEPT YOU
CAN'T BRING IT BACK IN HEAR SO
YOU HAVE TO EAT IT OUT THERE.
WE HAVE RULES.
IT'S A LIBRARY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE OTHER THING IS THAT THE BOOK
SALES WILL CONTINUE.
OKAY?
SO HELP YOURSELF THERE.
[ BRIEF BREAK ]
] ]   I KNOW I'M LOUD.
I'M FROM LOOK BRYNN.
I'M LOUD.
EVERYBODY COME ON IN.
THANK YOU KIDS FOR COMING.
I ACTUALLY TRIED TO BRIBE MY
KIDS TO COME BY TELLING THEM
THEY'D MISS SCHOOL, AND THEY
WENT TO SCHOOL.
THAT'S WHY I'M SO GLAD TO SEE
YOU GUYS.
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE WALTER
AWARDS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL --
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
OH, BY THE WAY, I FORGOT TO SAY,
MY NAME IS ELLEN OH.
I'M CEO AND CO-FOUNDER -- THANK
YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WILL YOU GUYS COME HOME WITH ME
AND DO THIS EVERY DAY?
I LOVE YOU GUYS!
WE ARE GRATEFUL AND HONORED TO
BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS FOR THE PAST
4 YEARS, AND PRESENT OUR AWARDS
IN THIS BEAUTIFUL AND HISTORIC
BUILDING.
THIS YEAR IS ALSO THE 5-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FOUNDING OF
THE "WE NEED DIVERSE BOOKS," THE
FIRST TWEETS -- YEAH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE FIRST TWEET WENT WITH THE
HASHTAG IN IT WENT OUT ON APRIL
24th, 2014, AND WNDB
INCORPORATED IN JULY OF THAT
YEAR, SO IT'S BEEN 5 YEARS, 5
CHALLENGING YEARS, THAT HAVE
TURNED MY HAIR COMPLETELY GRAY
LIKE BARACK OBAMA IN HIS LAST
TERM OF PRESIDENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT HAVE LEFT ME WITH TWO EYE
TWITCHES ON EITHER SIDE.
THIS ONE TWITCHES THIS WAY AND
THIS ONE TWITCHES THAT WAY AND
RANDOM STRANGERS THINK I'M
WINKING AT THEM.
BUT TRYING TO CHANGE THE STATUS
QUO HAS NEVER BEEN AN EASY FEAT.
WHEN WE STARTED OUT AS A
HASHTAG, NONE OF US KNEW THAT WE
WOULD END UP BUILDING A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FROM
SCRATCH!
AND DEVELOP CORE PROGRAMMING
DEDICATED TO HELP FIX THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE WERE RAISING
AWARENESS OF.
MANY OF MY TEAMMATES WHO STARTED
OUT WITH ME 5 YEARS AGO BURNED
OUT.
UTTERLY EXHAUSTED BY ALL THAT WE
WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
FORTUNATELY, MANY OTHERS STEPPED
UP.
AND KEPT WNDB RUNNING, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THEM.
DANIELLE CLAYTON, OUR COO, STAND
UP.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
JUDY SCHRICKER, JUDY, OUR CFO,
STAND UP, WHEREVER -- ARE YOU
HIDING?
AND THEN OF COURSE, CAROLYN
RICHMOND, OUR PROGRAM DIRECTOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I GOTTA BE HONEST:  I DON'T
THINK I WOULD HAVE MADE IT THIS
FAR WITHOUT THEM.
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN A
PERMIT ON SOME EYE-TWITCHY HER
MITT ON A REMOTE ISLAND WHERE NO
ONE HAS HEARD OF FACEBOOK OR
TWITTER OR INTERNET TROLLS AND
SIPPING COCONUT MILK.
WAIT A MINUTE, THIS SOUNDS
REALLY GOOD.
WHY DID YOU KEEP ME?
BUT WHAT A DIFFERENCE 5 YEARS
MAKES.
WE'VE GIVEN 16 GRANTS FOR
ASPIRING WRITERS AND
ILLUSTRATORS OF WHICH 5 HAVE
GONE ON TO GET THEIR OWN BOOK
DEALS.
IN FACT, THE MOST FAMOUS ONE IS
SOMEBODY CALLED ANGIE THOMAS FOR
A BOOK.
SHE WON OUR INAUGURAL WALTER
GRANT FOR A LITTLE BOOK CALLED
"THE HATE YOU GIVE" THAT HAS SAT
ON "THE NEW YORK TIMES" BEST
SELLER'S LIST FOR OVER 106
WEEKS, GUYS!
THAT IS PHENOMENAL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE'VE GIVEN OUT 33 INTERNSHIP
GRANTS FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
BECOME PUBLISHING INTERNS.
AND 21 OF THEM HAVE GOTTEN
FULL-TIME JOBS IN PUBLISHING!
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED 38
MENTORSHIPS THAT CONNECT
PROMISING WRITERS, ILLUSTRATORS
WITH SEASONED PROFESSIONALS, AND
GIVEN AWAY OVER 14,000 BOOKS TO
SCHOOLS NATIONWIDE, AND WE'VE
PUBLISHED 2 AMAZING ANTHOLOGIES,
WITH CROWN BOOKS PENGUIN RANDOM
HOUSE, OUR MIDDLE GRADE
ANTHOLOGY, FLYING LESSONS AND
OTHER STORIES, AND OUR YA
ANTHOLOGY, FRESH INC., AND THIS
YEAR, BECAUSE EVERY TIME I GO TO
A SCHOOL VISIT, THEY SAY:
WHERE ARE MORE ANTHOLOGIES?
THIS YEAR, WE HAVE ANOTHER
MIDDLE-GRADE ANTHOLOGY CALLED
THE HERO NEXT DOOR COMING OUT,
AND I'M SO EXCITED.
NOW, HERE'S ANOTHER LITTLE
STATISTIC:  WE HAD CONTESTS FOR
NEW UNPUBLISHED WRITERS IN ALL
THREE OF OUR ANTHOLOGIES, AND
ALL THREE OF THEM ARE OF OUR
CONTEST WINNERS HAVE GONE ON TO
GET THEIR OWN BOOK DEAL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YEAH, SO I FEEL LIKE WE'VE
TRULY ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH IN
THESE PAST 5 YEARS.
NOW, WHEN WE STARTED, "WE NEED
DIVERSE BOOKS," OUR GOAL WAS A
WORLD IN WHICH CHILDREN CAN SEE
THEMSELVES IN THE PAGES OF A
BOOK, RIGHT?
WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS THAT IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT SEEING OURSELVES.
IT'S THAT IT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE TO SEE THEMSELVES,
EVERYONE HAS TO SEE THEMSELVES
BEING TOLD IN THE PAGES OF A
BOOK.
WE HAVE TO READ THE STORIES OF
EVERYONE.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT STEREOTYPES AND
BAD REPRESENTATION, AND SEEK TO
EMPOWER AND ENRICH OUR
CHILDREN'S LIVES BY TEACHING
THEM TO BE EMPATHETIC.
NOW, CHILDREN DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY -- I MEAN, CHILDREN,
WAIT I SAID THAT WRONG.
CHILDREN HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR
GREAT EMPATHY, BUT THEY'RE NOT
BORN EMPATHETIC.
THEY MUST LEARN IT THROUGH
EDUCATION AND REAL-LIFE
EXPERIENCES, AND BOOKS ARE A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
WE NEED TO GIVE OUR KIDS BOOKS
THAT ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
WORLD THAT THEY LIVE IN, SO THAT
THEY CAN READ WIDELY AND
DIVERSELY AND MEET NEW PEOPLE,
NEW WORLDS, AND NEW FRIENDS
THROUGH THE PAGES OF A BOOK,
BECAUSE THEY CAN THEN BECOME THE
FUTURE THAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR.
WHICH IS WHY THIS AWARD CEREMONY
IS JUST SO VERY SPECIAL.
WE CELEBRATE THE VERY BEST OF
THE BOOKS THAT WE NEED TO SEE
THE MOST NOW, AND I HAVE TO SAY,
IT'S BEEN AMAZING TO SEE IT
GROW.
OUR FIRST YEAR OF THE WALTER
AWARDS, WE RECEIVED ONLY 50
SUBMISSIONS FOR CONSIDERATION
FROM PUBLISHERS.
THIS YEAR, THAT NUMBER HAS
JUMPED TO 244 SUBMISSIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YEAH.
OUR JUDGES HAD THEIR WORK CUT
OUT FOR THEM!
THIS IS A CHANGE THAT WE'VE BEEN
HOPING TO SEE.
AND NOW WNDB HAS A NEW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, WITH OVER 20 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN NONPROFIT
LEADERSHIP, PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
AND RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT, TO
HELP BUILD AN EVEN STRONGER
FUTURE FOR THIS WONDERFUL
ORGANIZATION THAT WE ALL SUPPORT
AND BELIEVE IN.
I'M SO PROUD TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, AND THE
PERSON WHO HAS STOPPED ME FROM
TWITCHING IN BOTH EYES, NICOLE
JOHNSON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   OH, MY GOSH.
GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
] ]   GOOD MORNING!
] ]   ELLEN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART
OF THIS DYNAMIC MOVEMENT TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD IN
AMERICA CAN SEE THEMSELVES IN A
BOOK.
YESTERDAY AND TODAY I'VE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO
MEET MY HEROES, AUTHORS,
ILLUSTRATORS, PUBLISHERS,
EDUCATORS AND LIBRARIANS WHO
WRITE OR PROMOTE THE BOOKS THAT
CHANGE CHILDREN'S LIVES.
I COME TO THIS WORK WITH A
BACKGROUND IN YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
OVER THE YEARS I HAVE WITNESSED
THE EMOTION A YOUNG CHILD OR A
TEENAGER EXPRESSES WHEN THEY
CONNECT WITH A BOOK.
SOMETIMES THEY CRY.
SOMETIMES THEY LAUGH.
BUT THEY ALWAYS HAD SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT.
AND A WAY TO UNDERSTAND
THEMSELVES AND THE WORLD AROUND
THEM.
THE AUTHORS WE CELEBRATE TODAY
ARE MASTERING THE ART OF
STORYTELLING.
THEY ARE SIGNALING TO CHILDREN
AND TEENS ACROSS THE COUNTRY:  I
SEE YOU.
MY TASK IN THESE FEW MINUTES
ACCOMPLISH A COUPLE THINGS, IS
TO OFFER ACKNOWLEDGMENT TO THE
TEAM OF VOLUNTEERS AND PARTNERS
WHO MADE THIS EVENT POSSIBLE.
FIRST, THE MANY WNDB VOLUNTEERS
WHO WORKING THE REGISTRATION AIR
YEAH AND BEHIND THE SCENES TO
KEEP THINGS MOVING TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR DEDICATING
YOUR TIME FOR US YEAR AFTER
YEAR.
WE HAVE MANY FOLKS WHO HAVE
RETURNED YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL TO THOSE WHO
SERVED ON THE WALTERS COMMITTEE
AND THE JUDGING COMMITTEE FOR
THIS EVENT.
SO FIRST OFF I WANT TO ASK THESE
FOLKS TO STAND, SO KATHIE AND
TERRI, OUR CO-DIRECTORS, WOULD
YOU GUYS STAND AND WAVE TO THE
AUDIENCE?
YES, I'M ASKING YOU TO STAND.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THE JUDGING COMMITTEE LED BY
ITS CHAIR, MARIA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND MEMBERS LEE, LORETTA, JULIA,
CANDACE, KATHIE, AND JOHN.
YOU GUYS WANT TO STAND UP?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THESE INDIVIDUALS STARTED
WORKING THE DAY AFTER OUR 2018
AWARDS CEREMONY.
THEY DEDICATED MANY HOURS TO
DESIGNING THIS EVENT, CONNECTING
WITH PUBLISHERS, READING AND
DISCUSSING EACH SUBMISSION,
RESULTING IN THE WINNERS AND
HONOREES THAT YOU SEE TODAY.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
PUBLISHING PARTNERS PENGUIN
RANDOM HOUSE OR DONATING COPIES
OF FLYING LESSONS AND FRESH INC.
TO OUR STUDENT ATTENDEES.
SPECIAL THANKS TO HARPER COLLINS
FOR DONATING COPIES OF THE
ANNIVERSARY EDITION OF MONSTER.
2019 MARKS THE 20th
ANNIVERSARY OF THIS GROUND
BREAKING WORK BY WALTER DEAN
MYERS.
THE STUDENTS ATTENDING WILL ALSO
RECEIVE COPIES OF THIS BOOK.
WNDB IS CELEBRATING -- GO AHEAD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WNDB IS CELEBRATING ITS -- OUR,
I'M PART OF THE FAMILY NOW, OUR
FOURTH YEAR OF GIVING THE WALTER
AWARDS AND OUR FOURTH YEAR OF
PARTNERING WITH THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS STAFF,
WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL COMMIT AND THE TIME
AND ENERGY THAT YOU GIVE TO THIS
EVENT.
YOU TRULY SERVE AS A PARTNER AN
EQUAL PARTNER IN HELPING US TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
SO THANK YOU.
AND IT IS WITH MY PLEASURE THAT
I WANT TO INTRODUCE A MEMBER OF
THAT TEAM, MS. SHARI ROSENSTEIN
WERB.
SHARI IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR LEARNING, LITERACY
AND ENGAGE FOR THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
SHE COMES FROM THE SMITHSONIAN
INSTITUTION WHERE FOR 10 YEARS
SHE WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION, OUTREACH AND VISITOR
EXPERIENCE PROGRAM AT THE
NATIONAL MUSEUM OF NATURAL
HISTORY.
SHE LED THE TRANSFORMATION OF
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
MUSEUM'S EXHIBITIONS COLLECTIONS
AND EXPERTS.
BEFORE KNOWING THE SMITHSONIAN
SHARI WENT MORE SEAN 17 YEARS AT
THE HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL MUSEUM,
WHERE SHE SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR
OF EDUCATIONAL AND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS AND AS A MUSEUM
EDUCATOR.
NARY IS COMMITTED TO BROADENING
EQUITY AND ACCESS TO EXPERIENCES
FOR DIVERSE AUDIENCES.
SHARI THANK YOU SO MUCH TO YOU
AND YOUR TEAM FOR MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
SHARI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
] ]   THANK YOU.
MORNING, EVERYONE.
THERE'S SUCH GREAT ENERGY IN
THIS ROOM TODAY.
AS I WAS WALKING IN, I NOTICED
SOME TAGS ON THE SEATS FROM
ALICE DEAL MIDDLE SCHOOL WHERE
MY OWN TWO SONS ATTENDED SO
WELCOME TO YOU ALL.
I'M HERE ACTUALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS
DR. CARLA HAYDEN WHO COULDN'T
HERE WITH US THIS MORNING BUT
I'M PLEASED TO ADD MY VOICE TO
THE CHORUS OF VOICES WELCOMING
YOU TO THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
THIS MORNING.
WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE HOSTED THIS
MORNING'S SYMPOSIUM ON DIVERSITY
IN CHILDREN'S LITERATURE, AND
ALSO TO BE HOSTING THIS
CEREMONY.
BOTH EVENTS HIGHLIGHT AND
PROMOTE BOOKS THAT BROADEN OUR
NOTIONS OF DIVERSITY, ENGAGE US
IN MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THEM, AND EMPHASIZE OUR
DESIRE FOR EVERY CHILD TO SEE
THEMSELVES IN THE PAGES OF A
BOOK.
TO HONOR EXEMPLARY DIVERSE
BOOKS, CREATED BY WRITERS AND
ILLUSTRATORS FROM MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES, WE NEED DIVERSE
BOOKS ESTABLISHED THE WALTER
DEAN MYERS AWARD FOR OUTSTANDING
CHILDREN'S LITERATURE, THE
WALTERS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, WALTER DEAN
MYERS WAS A 5 TIME WINNER IF THE
CORETTA SCHOOL KING AWARD AND
RECEIVED 2 NEW BARRY HONORS.
HE WAS NAMED THE THIRD
AMBASSADOR BY THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS, THE CHILDREN'S BOOK
COUNCIL AND EVERY CHILD A READER
IN 2012.
ALTHOUGH WALTER PASSED AWAY IN
2014, WE REMEMBER HIM TODAY AND
ARE DELIGHTED THAT THE WALTER
AWARDS SERVE TO CELEBRATE HIM.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
THE EMCEE FOR THIS MORNING'S
AWARDS CEREMONY, LINDA SUE PARK.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LINDA SUE PARK HAS BEEN WRITING
POEMS AND STORIES SINCE SHE WAS
4 YEARS OLD.
AND HER FAVORITE THING TO DO AS
A CHILD WAS READ.
SHE'S THE AUTHOR OF NUMEROUS
NOVELS, PICTURE BOOKS, AND
POETRY COLLECTIONS FOR CHILDREN.
HER WORK OFTEN USES HISTORICAL
SETTINGS AND INNOVATIVE FORMS TO
EXPAND YOUNG READERS' SENSE OF
THE POSSIBILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, HER POETRY
COLLECTION, TAPDANCING ON THE
ROOF, UTILIZES A KOREAN SYLLABIC
VERSE FORM TO BRING SURPRISE AND
HUMOR TO EVERY DAY MOMENTS AND
OBJECTS.
PARK'S NOVELS FOR MIDDLE GRADE
AND TEEN READERS INCLUDE NEWBERY
MEDALIST A SINGLE SHARD, WHEN MY
NAME WAS KAOKO, AND THE LONG
WALK TO WATER AS WELL AS THE
WINGING CLOTH FANTASY TRILOGY.
HER NEWEST PICTURE BOOK, WHICH
ISN'T EVEN OUT YET, BUT DUE OUT
THIS WEEK, IS GANDRA'S TREASURE.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
ADDRESSING THESE -- ADDRESSING
DIFFICULT TOPICS, BUT IT'S
REALLY ESPECIALLY GOOD WHEN YOU
CAN HAVE A PLAYFUL WAY OF
ENGAGING WITH THESE COMPLICATED
PERSONAL TOPICS.
THIS NEW BOOK IS A PLAYFUL LOOK
AT MIXED-RACE IDENTITY, WHICH IS
A REALLY EXCITING WAY OF
CONNECTING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE.
LINDA SUE GREW UP OUTSIDE
CHICAGO AND EARNED A B.A. AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND SHE
LIVES WITH HER FAMILY IN WESTERN
NEW YORK.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
LINDA SUE PARK TO THE PODIUM.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   WALTER DEAN, I GOT TO KNOW
HIM AS A COLLEAGUE ON THE
ADVISORY BOARD OF THE SOCIETY OF
CHILDREN'S BOOK WRITERS AND
ILLUSTRATORS.
I CONSIDERED HIM A MENTOR NOT
ONLY ABOUT WRITING, BUT ABOUT
THE WORLD AND LIFE AND
ESPECIALLY LIFE AS A PERSON OF
COLOR.
ABOUT 10 OR 12 YEARS AGO WE HAD
A CONVERSATION THAT LED DIRECTLY
TO ME STANDING HERE TODAY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY
IN THE CHILDREN'S BOOK WORLD
LONG BEFORE WNDB WAS EVEN A
TWINKLE IN ELLEN'S EYE, AND I
WAS FLAILING, I WAS FLINGING
IDEAS AROUND, WANTING
DESPERATELY TO DO SOMETHING
BEYOND MY OWN WRITING, SOMETHING
TO HELP CHANGE THE INDUSTRY, BUT
I HAD NO CLUE HOW TO START.
WALTER DEAN, WALTER DEAN CAN!
NO, WALTER DEAN, WALTER DEAN!
HE LISTENED SYMPATHETICALLY
WHILE I RAMBLED ON AND ON.
I WANTED TO PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIPS
TO THE NYU OR THE COLUMBIA
PUBLICING PROGRAMS BUT HOW WOULD
I EVER RAISE ENOUGH MONEY FOR
THAT?
I WANTED PUBLISHING
PROFESSIONALS TO GO INTO HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND TALK TO YOUNG PEOPLE NOT
ABOUT WRITING BUT ABOUT CAREERS
IN THE BOOK INDUSTRY:  EDITING,
MARKETING, SALES, PUBLICITY T I
WANTED TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET MORE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
OTHER DIVERSE IDENTITIES INTO
THE INTERNSHIP PIPELINE.
THAT'S IT, WALTER DEAN SAID TO
ME.
THAT'S THE BEST IDEA.
THOSE OF YOU WHO KNEW WALTER
DEAN WILL RECALL HIS
PRONOUNCEMENTS WERE AKIN TO
HEARING SOMETHING IN THE VOICE
OF GOD SO FORTH I WENT.
HE WASN'T ACTUALLY PERFECT.
WE HAD SO MANY ARGUMENTS ABOUT
RAP MUSIC, I CAN'T TELL YOU.
BUT FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS, I
TALKED ABOUT INTERNSHIPS TO
ANYONE WHO WOULD STAND STILL
LONG ENOUGH.
AND THEN ONE FATEFUL DAY IN
2014, ELLEN ASKED ME IF I WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH WNDB, AND I
SAID:  YEAH, BUT I'VE GOT A
CONDITION.
I WANT TO WORK ON INTERNSHIPS.
SHE SAID, OH, FINE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM.
SIGN ME UP!
I HAVE BEEN HONORARY CHAIR OF
THE INTERNSHIP PROGRAM COMMITTEE
SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
THIS MR. THE FIFTH YEAR OF THE
PROGRAM.
OUR FIRST WNDB INTERNS RECEIVED
THEIR GRANTS IN 2015, WHICH HAVE
GIVEN
OUT 33 GRANTS BUT 22 OF THE
INTERNSHIP GRANTEES NOW HAVE
FULL-TIME JOBS IN CHILDREN'S
PUBLISHING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THAT'S MORE THAN JUST A DROP IN
THE BUCKET, RIGHT?
THAT'S AT LEAST A RIPPLE AND
BECAUSE OF MY INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE INTERNSHIP COMMITTEE,
CAROLINE RICHMOND AND THE WALTER
AWARDS COMMITTEE HAVE HONORED ME
WITH THE INVITATION TO HOST THE
CEREMONY TODAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO STAND HERE AND
SAY WE DID IT, WALTER!
AND I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK HE'S
UP THERE.
I THINK HE'S OUT THERE.
BUT I WILL SAY WE'RE DOING IT
WALTER AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENCOURAGEMENT TO ME OVER ALL
THOSE YEARS.
NOW I HAVE THE INCREDIBLE HONOR
AND DELIGHT OF INTRODUCING
CHRISTOPHER MYERS.
LAST NAME MIGHT SOUND FAMILIAR.
CHRIS'S BOOKS HAVE WON CALDECOTT
HONORS AND CORETTA SCOTT KING
HONORS AND THE BOSTON GLOBE HORN
BOOK HONOR.
WIDELY ACCLAIMED FOR HIS WORK
WITH LITERATURE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
HE'S ALSO AN ACCOMPLISHED FINE
ARTIST WHO HAS LECTURED AND
EXHIBITED INTERNATIONALLY.
HIS PRACTICE CAN BE DIVIDED INTO
TWO CATEGORIES:  INTERVENTIONS
IN HISTORICAL NARRATIVES AND
WORK CRAFTED WITH ARTISANS FROM
AROUND THE GLOBE FROM PLACES AS
DISPARATE AS EGYPT, VIETNAM,
INDONESIA, BROOKLYN.
CHRIS IS ALSO THE CREATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NEW IMPRINT MAKE
ME A WORLD AT RANDOM HOUSE
CHILDREN'S BOOKS WHICH IS
DEDICATED TO EXPLORING THE VAST
POSSIBILITIES OF CONTEMPORARY
CHILDHOOD.
HE MAKES HIS OWN CLOTHES.
A FEW CENTURIES AGO, SOMEONE
LIKE CHRIS WOULD HAVE MAYBE BEEN
CALLED A RENAISSANCE MAN.
WELL, I SAY:  STEP ASIDE,
DaVINCI, BECAUSE WE'VE GOT
CHRIS MYERS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   HI, Y'ALL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S SO GOOD TO HEAR SO MANY
SWEET THINGS SAID ABOUT MAY
FATHER, RIGHT?
IT'S REALLY NICE.
IT'S ALMOST ENOUGH TO MAKE YOU
FORGET SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
ABOUT HIM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'LL TELL YOU A LITTLE STORY.
IT'S ABOUT 5.5 YEARS A I GO,
MAYBE 6.
I WAS INVITED TO GO TO PAPUA,
NEW GUINEA, WHICH IS JUST
FOREVER AWAY.
IT'S LIKE 9 PLANE RIDES.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO AUSTRALIA,
THEN YOU HAVE TO GO TO PORT
MOORESBY WHICH IS A LITTLE JENKY
TOWN BUT IT'S THE CAPITAL,
WHATEVER.
FROM THERE I FLEW TO ANOTHER
TOWN CALLED ALATAU AND FROM
THERE I GOT ON A BOAT.
AND ON THIS BOAT I WENT FROM
ISLAND TO ISLAND TO ISLAND.
PAPUA NEW GUINEA IS ALL TINY,
TINY, TINY ISLANDS.
MY FATHER SAID, AND I QUOTE:
WHY YOU GOING TO PAPUA, NEW
GUINEA, MAN?
AND I SAID, WELL, SOMEONE IS
PAYING FOR A PLANE TAKE.
HE SAID WELL, ALL RIGHT, I MEAN,
IF THEY'RE PAYING FOR THE PLANE
TICKET.
I GET TO ONE OF THESE TINY
ISLANDS.
I GET OFF THE BOAT THAT I'M ON
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THIS
ISLAND ARE EXCITED TO SEE
SOMEONE GET OFF A BOAT WHO'S NOT
WHITE, RIGHT?
THEY'RE BROWN PEOPLE.
THEY RECOGNIZE, GAME RECOGNIZE
GAME.
AND THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
LIKE:  OH, HELLO!
I WAS LIKE HEY, HOW YOU DOING?
SO I'M SITTING ON THIS ISLAND IN
PAPUA, NEW GUINEA, AND I REALIZE
AFTER WALKING AROUND A LITTLE
BIT THAT THERE WERE NO MIRRORS
ON THE ISLAND, AND THERE WERE NO
PHOTOS ON THE ISLAND.
THERE WAS NO ELECTRICITY ON THE
ISLAND.
ALL THE HOUSES ARE THATCH HUTS
ON STILTS.
THERE'S ONE SCHOOL THAT IS MADE
OF CORRUGATED TIN.
IN THERE, OF COURSE, BECAUSE I
AM AT CORE A BOOK PERSON, THE
BOOKS ARE ALL BRITISH COLONIAL
BOOKS, RIGHT?
AND SO WE'RE ON THIS ISLAND,
WITH ALMOST NO IMAGES, RIGHT?
THERE WAS ONE GUY WHO HAD A
PHOTO OF HIS GRANDFATHER.
HIS GRANDFATHER HAD PLAYED
SOCCER, AND THEREFORE LEFT THE
ISLAND, AND WENT TO PORT
MOORESBY, THERE WAS A PHOTO OF
HIM ON THE SOCCER TEAM AND THAT
WAS STUCK TO THE THATCH ROOF
SIDE OF THE HUT.
SO I WAS STRUCK BY BOTH THE
UNIVERSALITY OF OUR PROBLEMS,
RIGHT?
THAT EVEN IN THE THATCH ROOF
HUTS OF ANACOSTIA OR OF HARLEM
OR BROOKLYN, WE'RE STILL
STARVING FOR IMAGES AND I WAS
STRUCK BY THE IMMEDIACY OF WHAT
I COULD DO AND SO I SAT DOWN
WITH MY PAD AND MY INK AND MY
BRUSHES, AND I DID WHAT I DO
EVERYWHERE:  I SAID, CAN I MAKE
SOME IMAGES?
AND I PAINTED ALL THE KIDS ON
THIS ISLAND.
RIGHT?
THE ISLAND HAS GOT MAYBE 250
PEOPLE.
OF THOSE 250 PEOPLE, THERE'S,
LIKE, 75 THAT ARE KIDS.
SO I SAT THERE AND I JUST
WAITED, AND THE LONG LINE
STARTED.
AND IF YOU GO TO THIS ISLAND
THIS DAY ON THE SIDE OF THESE
THATCH ROOF HUTS YOU'LL SEE ALSO
LITTLE PAINTINGS OF THESE KIDS.
AS I WAS LEAVING THE ISLAND A
GUY NAMED EDISON, THAT WAS HIS
NAME, BECAUSE AGAIN COLONIALISM
IS A BIG THING.
REALLY, FOLKS CAME OUT AND THEY
WERE WEARING TRADITIONAL GARB
FROM THOUSANDS OF YEARS AND THE
DUDE INTRODUCED HIMSELF, THE GUY
WHO SPOKE ENGLISH SAID HELLO,
I'M EDISON.
I SAID OH, ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HE SAID, THANK YOU, AND THANK
YOU FOR MY FAMILY.
AND HE KIND OF GESTURED AT THE
REST OF THE ISLAND.
ONE OF THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO WAS
ON THIS BOAT WITH ME SAID, IS
HE, LIKE, THE FATHER OF EVERYONE
ON THE ISLAND?
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I DIDN'T QUITE KNOW WHAT TO
SAY.
EXCEPT THAT I WAS ABLE TO -- I
WANTED TO COMMUNICATE TO THE
PEOPLE ON THE BOAT WITH ME
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
NEEDED SOME EDUCATION THAT THERE
ARE FAMILY STRUCTURES BEYOND
WHAT YOU MAY KNOW.
THIS HERE IS PART OF A FAMILY.
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE TO THE WORK
THAT WE ARE DOING IS FAMILY.
AND THIS IS A SPECIAL, SPECIAL
MOMENT IN THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS TO BE HERE WITH FAMILY.
THIS IS THAT UNORTHODOX FAMILY
STRUCTURE THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
AND LIKE ALL FAMILIES, WE'VE GOT
CHARACTERS AND WE'VE GOT
CONFLICT.
WE'VE GOT UNEXPECTED GUEST STARS
AND WE'VE GOT CAN'T-GET-RATE
COUSINRIGHT
COUSINS, TIGER MOMS.
AUNTS WITH SECRET LIVES, LINDA
SUE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SLACKER NEPHEWS AND COOL UNCLES:
JASON.
JASON IS THE COOL UNCLE FOR
EVERYBODY, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND WE WILL FIGHT AMONGST
OURSELVES, LIKE ALL THE GOOD
UNORTHODOX FAMILIES THAT I KNOW.
AND AS WE ALL SEE THAT WE HAVE
GOALS, WE WANT TO CHANGE THE
INDUSTRY.
WE WANT TO CHANGE THE LIVES OF
THE CHILDREN THAT WE MEET, THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
CARE ABOUT AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE CONFLICT IN THAT MISSION
AND I THINK THAT 5 YEARS IN IS A
GOOD TIME TO NOTE THAT, AND TO
NOTE THAT OFTENTIMES, I'VE BEEN
PART OF THESE CONVERSATIONS FOR
A LONG TIME.
I REMEMBER POP TALKING TO ME
ABOUT, MAN, LINDA SUE, SHE'S GOT
HER HEAD ON.
SHE'S THINKING ABOUT IT.
SHE'S REALLY DOING IT.
SHE'S THINKING OUTSIDE OF HER,
JUST HER BOOKS, AND SHE'S TRYING
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN A
LARGER SENSE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
CONFLICT, AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT EACH
OTHER AND SAY:  I KNOW YOU'RE ON
THE SAME SIDE, EVEN THOUGH I
DON'T LIKE THE WAY YOU'RE GOING
ABOUT SOLVING THIS PROBLEM, BUT
ALL OF THESE SOLUTIONS TOGETHER,
THAT IS WHAT MAKES THE RIPPLE
INTO A WAVE.
AND WE'RE AT THAT MOMENT WHERE 5
YEARS, WE'RE ALL REAL.
WE'RE HERE.
WE'RE STILL A FAMILY.
AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT.
YOU KNOW, AND LIKE FAMILIES, I
THINK PEOPLE ASSUME, ESPECIALLY
WITH MY POP, THAT I GREW UP WITH
SOMEBODY WHO WAS LIKE:  LET YOUR
CREATIVE HEART SING, MY CHILD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DID NOT.
I GREW UP WITH A WRITER WHO WAS
CRITICAL AND SLIGHTLY MEAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I GREW UP WITH SOMEONE WHO, WHEN
I WAS VERY YOUNG, I WASN'T
ALLOWED TO SAY I HAD AN IDEA FOR
A BOOK.
I HAD TO GIVE HIM AN OUTLINE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL GOOD TRAINING.
BUT THAT KIND OF DEBATE THAT
EVERY CREATIVE PERSON IN THIS
ROOM UNDERSTANDS FOR THEMSELVES,
BECAUSE YOU'VE HAD THAT FIGHT
WITH THE BOOKS THAT YOU'VE
WRITTEN.
YOU'VE HAD THAT FIGHT WITH
YOURSELF.
THAT IS THE KIND OF FATE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE TOGETHER.
AND IT'S SO GOOD TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ON THESE STAGES
WHERE WE THINK ABOUT THINGS
LIKE, WELL, DO WE WANT TO THINK
OF THE EXPERIENCE OF BEING A
PERSON OF COLOR IN THIS COUNTRY
AS BEING SIMPLY ABOUT TRAUMA?
HOW DO WE HOLD TRAUMA?
HOW DO WE NOT HOLD IT?
IS THERE A WAY TO LET IT GO?
THESE ARE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
AND JUST LIKE MY FATHER SAT
THERE AND SAID, "MAN, THAT DON'T
SOUND RIGHT," I'M LIKE, BUT IT
WOULD BE A GOOD STORY AND IT
WOULD SELL.
AND HE GOES, YEAH, BUT WE CAN DO
BETTER.
THAT'S OUR JOB.
WE'RE GOING PLACES AS A FAMILY.
WE ARE TRYING TO BUILD A WAY
FORWARD, AND IT'S A GIFT TO SEE
THE CONTINUITY OF THIS FAMILY.
BECAUSE AS I SAID, I'VE BEEN
SEEING THIS SINCE I WAS A KID,
WITH SITTING WITH NICOLASA
MOORE, SHEILA HANAKA, HARRY
YEPP, FOLKS WHO HAVE PASSED OR
WE LOVED, THIS IS THE CONTINUITY
OF FAMILY.
THAT'S WHAT FAMILY MEANS.
AND SO WE FIND OURSELVES HERE,
THROWN UP ON AN ISLAND, WITH
THIS VERY FEW IMAGES.
THERE'S NOT MIRRORS, PERHAPS.
THERE'S NOT PHOTOS.
AND OUR JOB IS TO DO WHAT I DID
ON THAT ISLAND THAT DAY -- WE
SIT THERE, AND WE SIT AND WE
DRAW EACH AND EVERY KID, AND WE
MAY THIS -- WE HOPE THAT ALL OF
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE CAN
EVENTUALLY PASTE THEIR PICTURE
ON THE SIDE OF THEIR THATCH-ROOF
HUT AND THEY WILL PASTE THE
PICTURES THAT ARE WRITTEN BY THE
NEW PEOPLE WRITING, THE
TIFFANIES, THE VEERAS, THE
EMILYS, THE ELIZABETHS, THE
DAVIDS,.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
BECAUSE WE ARE A FAMILY.
WE LOOK OUT FOR EACH OTHER AND I
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE
CONTINUITY OF MY OWN FAMILY BOTH
THE VERY PERSONAL ONE, AND THE
LARGER ONE OF PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT BOOKS FOR KIDS.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR KEEPING THAT
CONTINUITY GOING.
THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   GEE, THANKS, CHRIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ONE MORE SHOUT-OUT, WHEN I
TALKED ABOUT THE INTERNSHIPS,
WHICH IS TO MY AMAZING
COMMITTEE, THE INTERNSHIP
COMMITTEE WORKS THEIR BEHINDS
OFF, AND I JUST GET TO SIGN THE
LETTERS.
SO THEY'RE THE ONES WHO DO THE
REAL WORK, AND IF ANY OF THEM
ARE WATCHING THE LIVE-STREAM,
THANKS, GUYS!
ALL RIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON NOW TO THE PRESENTATION OF
THE WALTERS FOR THE YOUNGER
READER CATEGORY.
THIS MORNING, MEG INTRODUCED THE
HONOR WINNERS IN THE SYMPOSIUM
WHICH I HOPE MOST OF YOU WERE
ABLE TO ATTEND, BECAUSE IT
ROCKED!
AND THEIR FULL BIOS ARE IN THE
PROGRAMS.
I WOULD ESPECIALLY DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THEIR WEBSITES OR
OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA HANDLES WHERE
YOU CAN HAVE THEM 24/7 IN YOUR
HOMES, IF YOU LIKE!
SO I WILL BE GIVING YOU JUST A
FEW OTHER LITTLE FUN FACTS ABOUT
THEM.
AND I'M GOING TO BEGIN WITH
DAVID BOWLES.
DAVID IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING A
TV SERIES BASED ON HIS BOOK,
BORDER LORE, AND THIS YEAR,
PENGUIN WILL PUBLISH THE CHUPIC
OPERAS OF THE RIO GRANDE.
TWO BOOKS WILL RELEASE CLOCK
WORK CORANDERA, A GRAPHIC NOVEL
ILLUSTRATED BY RAUL III.
AND IN 2017, DAVID WAS INDUCTED
INTO THE TEXAS INSTITUTE OF
LETTERS IN RECOGNITION OF HIS
LITERARY ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
ABOUT THEY CALL ME GÜERO, ONE
PANELIST DESCRIBES THE BOOK AS:
SO RELATABLE, WITH THAT FEELING
OF BEING CLOSE TO THE READER'S
EXPERIENCE, AND SINGULAR AT THE
SAME TIME.
DAVID, WILL YOU PLEASE COME UP
AND ACCEPT YOUR WALTER HONOR FOR
"THEY CALL ME GÜERO."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY.
] ]   GO LIKE THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
] ]   VEERA HIRANANDANI'S BOOK,
THE NIGHT DIARY, HAS BEEN
FEATURED ON NPR'S WEEKEND
EDITION, IS A "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITOR'S CHOICE PICK, AND WAS
CHOSEN AS A 2018 BEST CHILDREN'S
BOOK OF THE YEAR BY "THE NEW
YORK TIMES," THE WASHINGTON
POST, NPR, AMAZON SCHOOL LIBRARY
JOURNAL, KIRKUS REVIEWS, AMONG
OTHERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AS A KID, SHE LOVED PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES ESPECIALLY PACK MAN.
THAT'S OLD-SCHOOL.
HER FAVORITE COMFORT FOODS ARE
JEWISH MATZO BALL SOUP AND
INDIAN SAMOSAS.
COMMENTS FROM THE PANEL:  THE
NIGHT DIARY IS SIMPLY
OUTSTANDING HISTORICAL FICTION
THAT HONORS AND REVEALS THE
COMPLEXITY OF PAST EVENTS.
VEERA, PLEASE COME UP AND ACCEPT
YOUR WALTER HONOR FOR "THE NIGHT
DIARY.
"
[ APPLAUSE ]
JEWELL PARKER RHODES.
JEWELL!
GOT THE PERFECT NAME, RIGHT?
JEWELL PARKER RHODES' MIDDLE
GRADE BOOKS HAVE WON THE CORETTA
SCOTT KING HONOR, THE JANE ADAMS
CHILDREN'S BOOK AWARD AND MORE.
SHE'S THE VIRGINIA G. PIPER
ENDOWED CHAIR IN CREATIVE
WRITING AT ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND SHE'S WRITTEN
MANY AWARD WINNING BOOKS FOR
ADULTS THAT WE DON'T CARE ABOUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SHE BEGAN COLLEGE AS A DANCE
MAJOR BUT WHEN SHE DISCOVERED
THERE WERE NOVELS BY AFRICAN
AMERICANS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
SHE KNEW SHE WANTED TO BE AN
AUTHOR.
SHE GREW UP IN A THREE STORY
BRICK HOUSE IN PITTSBURGH RAISED
BY HER GRANDPARENTS AND IT WAS
HER GRANDMOTHER WHO TAUGHT HER
HOW TO TELL STORIES.
FROM THE PANELISTS:  I LOVE THE
MESSAGE OF AGENCY AND POWER THAT
TRANSCENDS LIFE ITSELF AND
VICTORY FROM PEOPLE WHO TRY TO
CRUSH IT.
GHOST BOYS PRESENTS A POWERFUL
AND TIMELY STORY IN A WAY THAT
IS ACCESSIBLE TO MIDDLE-GRADE
READERS.
RIPPLES OF THE PAST REMAIN IN
THE PRESENT AND CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE FUTURE.
READERS, PLEASE WELCOME TO THE
STAGE THE WINNER OF THE WALTER
AWARD FOR YOUNGER READERS FOR
"GHOST BOYS," JEWELL PARKER
RHODES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   I'VE ALREADY STARTED
CRYING.
I WANT TO THANK
WNDB AND "WE NEED DIVERSE
BOOKS" AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THIS IS SUCH AN HONOR AND THIS
IS ALSO THE CAPSTONE OF MY
CAREER, IT REALLY AND TRULY IS.
WHEN I WAS ASKED TO WRITE "GHOST
BOYS" BY ALVENA LANE, MY EDITOR
LITTLE BROWN, OH, JEWELL, DO YOU
WANT TO WRITE ABOUT THE MURDER
OF BLACK BOYS?
WHAT DO YOU SAY, NO?
OF COURSE NOT.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
IT'S TOO HARD.
STYLISTICALLY, IT'S TOO HARD.
EMOTIONALLY.
BUT MAY TWO EDITORS ALVENA LING
AND ALLISON MOORE KNEW THAT I
HAD BEEN GOING THROUGH A LOT OF
INCIDENCES WATCHING AS MY YOUNG
CHILD GREW AND BECAME THE
SUBJECT OF MORE RACISM AND
RACIAL BIAS.
I ALSO HAD CHILDHOOD MEMORIES OF
EMMA TILL.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP, THE
PICTURES OF EMMA TILL IN THIS
COFFIN ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF HIS
DEATH WERE JUST STREWN
THROUGHOUT OUR HOME.
WE WERE ENGAGED IN SEEING RACISM
IN OUR WORLD I THINK BECAUSE MY
GRANDPARENTS WANTED TO PROTECT
US IN THEIR WAY FROM RACISM.
BUT THE IMAGES OF EMMETT HAVE
HAUNTED ME FOR OVER 65 YEARS,
AND I STILL SEE IMAGES OF MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WERE LYNCHED,
BURNED, AND CORKSCREWED, SOME
BEFORE AND SOME POST-DEATH.
SO IN MY HEART, I KEPT HAVING
THIS STEW OF PASSION, AND I
THOUGHT I HAD BEEN WRITING ALL
THESE YEARS, PRACTICING SO HARD,
THAT WHY NOT TRY TO WRITE THIS
IMPOSSIBLE BOOK?
AND, IN FACT, LINDA, ALL THOSE
ADULT NOVELS THAT I WROTE, WHICH
WE CAN FORGET ABOUT --
[ LAUGHTER ]
-- THOSE WERE, IN FACT, MY
PRACTICE BOOKS FOR TRYING TO
BECOME GOOD ENOUGH TO WRITE FOR
CHILDREN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YES.
THANK YOU.
SO I LIKE HARD THINGS, HARD
BOOKS.
SO I SAID:  SURE, I'LL GIVE IT A
TRY.
AND I MENTIONED TO ALVENA:
OKAY, I CAN WRITE IT IF I HAVE
GHOSTS, AND ONLY YEARS LATER DID
SHE TELL ME SHE WAS REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND DID NOT UNDERSTAND.
BUT I WENT AHEAD AND STARTED THE
BOOK, AND FOR 2.5 YEARS, THE
BOOK NEARLY UNDID ME.
I WOULD WRITE 28 PAGES, AND THEN
SEND THEM OFF TO ALVENA AND SAY:
THAT'S IT, I'M DONE.
AND SHE'D SAY:  IT'S A LITTLE
SHORT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN I'D WRITE SOME MORE,
SEND IT OFF TO ALVENA AND
ALLISON:  THAT'S IT, I'M DONE!
IT CAME OUT IN BITS AND PIECES,
AND IN BETWEEN, I WOULD READ THE
COLOR OF LAW.
I WOULD READ "MERCY," I WOULD
STUDY MORE HISTORY AND I WOULD
JUST WEEP AND CRY.
BUT WHO WAS MY LODE STAR?
WALTER DEAN MYERS.
I HAD READ HIS BOOKS AS A
TEENAGER, AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
SCHOLAR, AND AS A MOTHER WITH MY
DAUGHTER, AND IN MY HEART, I
KNEW THAT TO BE 1/10 AS
TALENTED, IMAGINATIVE, CREATIVE
AS WALTER DEAN MYERS, I JUST
MIGHT MAKE IT THROUGH.
HIS COMMITMENT TO THE LEGACY OF
DIVERSITY, HIS COMMITMENT TO
EXCELLENCE, JUST SHY SHINED.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT I PICKED UP?
MONSTER.
AND IT SEEMED SO RIGHT THAT
TODAY IS 20th ANNIVERSARY
PUBLICATION DATE OF "MONSTER,"
AND I'M HERE ACCEPTING HIS
AWARD.
I GOT TO MEET HIM.
WHEN I FINALLY STARTED MY FIRST
BOOK FOR CHILDREN, 9th WARD,
AND I WAS AT THE CORETTA SCOTT
KING AWARDS, AND GUESS WHO WAS
STANDING BEHIND ME?
OH, I FANGIRLED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WAS EMBARRASSING.
I WAS A SHRIMP.
HE WAS JUST SO WONDERFUL, AND I
WAS SO STRUCK BY HIS KINDNESS.
HIS HUMILITY.
HE WAS JUST ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL
AND I THOUGHT THIS WAS A SIGN
THAT, YES, I WAS FINALLY A
CHILDREN'S AUTHOR.
AND I CALLED MY DAUGHTER, KELLY,
AND SAID:  GUESS WHO I MET
TODAY?
AND I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, I WAS COOL FOR MY
DAUGHTER!
I WAS SO, SO COOL.
SO I TOLD KID INSPIRATION, HIS
LODE STAR OF EXCELLENCE AND I
BEGAN WRITING "GHOST BOYS."
NOW, I ALWAYS FELT THAT EMMETT
TILL WAS INNOCENT, THAT HE DID
NOT SAY:  HEY, BABY.
HE DID NOT WHISTLE AT MISS
CAROLYN BRYANT.
HE WAS NOT SEXUALLY ASSAULTTIVE.
AND YET FOR OVER 60 YEARS, THERE
WAS ALL THESE BOOKS THAT I READ,
INCLUDING BOOKS FOR CHILDREN,
ALL THIS NEWS ON THE INTERNET
THAT ALWAYS SUGGESTED THAT
SOMEHOW, THE VICTIM MAY HAVE
DONE SOMETHING WRONG.
WELL, TO ME, THAT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT I WROTE THE STORY, WROTE THE
SCENE, AND THEN BILL BRYSON CAME
OUT WITH HIS BOOK CALLED, THE
BLOOD OF EMMETT TILL, IN HIS
MISS CAROLYN BRYANT FINALLY
SAID, AT THE AGE OF 82, "I LIED.
THAT BOY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WORTH DYING FOR.
AND IN FACT, THIS IS WHAT AS FAR
AS WE KNOW EMMETT TRULY DID."
HE WALKED INTO A STORE, READY
TO GET SOME CANDY.
HE GAVE HER THE PENNY FOR THE
CANDY, AND HE MAYBE, JUST MAYBE,
MIGHT HAVE TOUCHED HER FINGERS,
OR HER PALM, WHICH WAS SOMETHING
YOU SHOULDN'T DO.
YOU DIDN'T TOUCH A WHITE WOMAN
IN 1950s, BUT WHO KNOWS, YOU
KNOW?
AND THEN AFTERWARDS, HE WALKED
TO THE DOOR AND HE TURNED AROUND
AND SAID, GOODBYE.
THAT'S IT!
AND I SPOKE TO MY WONDROUS
EDITORS AT LITTLE BROWN ALLISON
AND ALVENA, AND I SAID, OH, SEND
ME BACK MY MANUSCRIPT, BECAUSE
IT WAS ALREADY IN COPY EDITING,
RIGHT?
AND I SAID SEND IT BACK.
AND I WAS ABLE TO REWRITE THAT
SCENE, WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
REAL TRUTH, THAT THE CHILD WAS
INNOCENT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AH, EMMETT.
I ALSO LATER ON, BECAUSE THE
BOOKS STAY WITH ME AND I JUST
THINK AND DREAM ABOUT THEM, WAS
ABLE TO MAKE ANOTHER CHANGE,
NAMELY AFTER THE BOOK WAS IN AN
ARC, AND CARLOS WHO HAS GIVEN
MAY CHARACTER JEROME THE TOY GUN
HAS THIS MOMENT WITH HIS FATHER
SAYING THAT HE FEELS GUILTY
ABOUT GIVING THIS TOY GUN, BUT
THERE'S A BEAT THAT I MISSED,
NAMELY THAT AS A CHILD OF COLOR,
AS AN HISPANIC AMERICAN, IT
COULD EQUALLY HAVE BEEN CARLOS
WHO WAS SHOT, TOO SO THAT TO ME
WAS IMPORTANT TO ADD IN, THAT
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO BE AFRICAN
AMERICAN, BUT SIMPLY A CHILD OF
COLOR, AND OUR SOCIETY CAN MAKE
AN EXCUSE FOR WHY YOU, AMONG
OTHERS, DO NOT DESERVE TO LIVE.
SO ONCE AGAIN, MAY WONDROUS MY
WONDEROUS
EDITORS SAID OKAY, JEWELL, HUG,
HUG, HUG.
OKAY, JEWELL, WILL YOU MAKE THIS
CHANGE?
ALVENA LINK AT LITTLE BROWN IS
THE KIND OF EDITOR THAT ALWAYS
ASKS THE PROBING QUESTIONS THAT
SORT OF TOOK ME DOWN ANOTHER
PATH, AND LAIRING THE NOVEL AND
FOR THAT, I'M ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL.
ALLISON MOORE KNOWS A JEWELL
PARKER RHODES SENTENCE BETTER
THAN I KNOW IT MYSELF, SO THESE
TWO WOMEN WERE WONDROUS, AND I
HONOR YOU.
IT DOES INDEED TAKE A VILLAGE.
NOW, I'M GOING TO TELL Y'ALL A
SECRET, OKAY?
IN 2014, MY DAUGHTER JUST HAD
HER BABY, AND EVERYBODY HAD TOLD
HER THAT IF YOU'RE A WRITER, YOU
CAN'T BE A MOM.
YOUR LIFE IS OVER.
AND IN FACT, WHEN I BECAME A
MOM, THAT WAS WHEN MY LIFE
BEGAN, AND PARTICULARLY AS A
WRITER, I TRIED SO HARD, BECAUSE
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO SAY TO MY
LITTLE GIRL:  DON'T GIVE UP.
SO HERE'S KELLY, AND I'M TELLING
HER, YOU'RE GOING TO BE ALL
RIGHT.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ALL RIGHT.
AND SHE APPLIES FOR A WNDB
FELLOWSHIP, AND SHE WAS ONE OF
THE YOUNG MENTEES SELECTED, AND
SHE WILL HAVE HER BOOK PUBLISHED
NEXT YEAR, 2020.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT'S CALLED AGNES AND THE END OF
THE WORLD.
Y'ALL UNDERSTAND AS HER MAMA
WHAT I HAD TO SAY HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT.
THAT AS A MAMA YOU CAN DISCOUNT
IT.
YES, YOU'RE GOOD.
YOU'RE MY MAMA.
WE NEED DIVERSE BOOKS.
YOU'RE CHANGING THE WORLD.
YOU'RE MAKING THINGS BETTER.
YOU'RE MAKING SO CHILDREN CAN
SEE THEMSELVES.
YOU ARE CAUSING INTERNSHIPS,
MORE PEOPLE WHO ARE OPEN TO THE
VARIOUS CULTURES AND ALL THE
MULTIPLICITY OF HUMANITY.
AND YOU ARE ENCOURAGING YOUNG
WRITERS LIKE MY DAUGHTER TO TELL
THEIR STORIES, TO TELL THEIR
TRUTH.
AND I AM FOREVER GRATEFUL.
SO FINALLY, I WANT TO THANK MY
EDITORS, ALVENA AND ALLISON.
I WANT TO THANK KELLY FOR BEING
MY DAUGHTER, SHARING STORIES AND
WRITING DREAMS WITH ME.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
WHO SELECTED "GHOST BOYS."
AND I'M GLAD I WROTE IT, I
REALLY AM, AND IF I NEVER WRITE
ANOTHER BOOK AGAIN, THIS WAS THE
BOOK I WAS MEANT TO WRITE.
AND I WANT TO THANK "WE NEED
DIVERSE BOOKS" FOR ALL THAT YOU
HAVE DONE, AND, ELLEN, I LOVE
YOU SO.
AND DEAR WALTER!
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
EVERY GOODBYE AIN'T GONE.
FOR ME AS A WRITER, YOUR
PRESENCE IS NEVER MORE NEAR.
PRESENCE IS NEVER MORE DEAR.
THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   THIS IS SO FUN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO THE
PRESENTATION OF THE WALTER
AWARDS IN THE TEEN CATEGORY.
TIFFANY D. JACKSON.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IN HER OTHER LIFE, TIFFANY HAS
MANAGED LIVE EVENTS, CONCERTS,
FESTIVALS, SHOW CASES SUCH AS
THE B. THE, T. AWARDS AND THE
SOUTH BY SOUTHWEST MUSIC SHOW
CASE.
AS A TEEN, SHE LOVED READING R.
R.L. STINE.
YEAH.
HER FAVORITE FOOD IS SOUL FOOD,
FRIED CHICKEN, MAC AND CHEESE,
CANDIED YAMS, CORN BREAD, YELLOW
CAKE WITH CHOCOLATE FROSTING OR
HER MOM'S SWEET POTATO PIE.
HER NEXT BOOK WHICH I CANNOT
WAIT TO SEE, IS:  LET ME HEAR A
RHYME, TO BE PUBLISHED BY
CATHERINE TIEGEN BOOKS IN MAY,
RIGHT?
YEAH, MAY, SOON.
WE DON'T HAVE LONG TO WAIT.
REGARDING MONDAY'S NOT COMING,
THE PANEL APPRECIATES THE VOICE
AND THE WAY THE TELLING OF THE
STORY CAN BE REDEMPTIVE AND
STILL HONOR THE TRUTH ABOUT A
TRAGEDY.
TIFFANY, WILL YOU PLEASE COME UP
AND ACCEPT YOUR WALTER HONOR FOR
"MONDAY'S NOT COMING."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   AND THE SUIT, RIGHT?
AM I RIGHT, THE SUIT?
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
EMILY X.R. PAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE X.R. STANDS FOR HER CHINESE
NAME.
SHE IS CO-CREATOR OF FORESHADOW,
A SERIAL Y.A. ANTHOLOGY WITH
NOVA RANSUMA.
I DON'T KNOW HOW PEOPLE DO THESE
THINGS.
LIKE WRITING BOOKS IS NOT
ENOUGH.
HER NUMBER ONE PEACE OF ADVICE
FOR ASPIRING WRITERS IS READ AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE, AND READ A
WIDE VARIETY.
THE PANEL CALLED THE ASTONISHING
COLOR OF AFTER:  IMMERSIVE AND
MOVING, IN SUCH A GRACEFUL WAY
OF BLENDING FANTASY AND
DISCOVERY OF HERITAGE.
EMILY, PLEASE COME UP AND ACCEPT
YOUR WALTER HONOR FOR "THE
ASTONISHING COLOR OF AFTER."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH, BOY.
LIZ, LIZ, LIZ.
ELIZABETH ACEVEDO IS THE AUTHOR
OF:  THE POET X.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YEAH.
WHICH WON THE A.L.A. PRINCE
AWARD, THE 2018 NATIONAL BOOK
AWARD FOR YOUNG PEOPLE'S
LITERATURE, THE BOSTON GLOBE
HORN BOOK AWARD AND WAS A KIRKUS
PRIZE FINALIST.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE ONES WHERE
YOU'VE GOT NO MORE ROOM FOR NO
MORE STICKERS ON THAT COVER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SHE'S A NATIONAL POETRY SLAM
CHAMPION.
SHE HOLDS AN MFA IN CREATIVE
WRITING FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND.
AND HER NEXT BOOK, WITH THE FIRE
ON HIGH -- GREAT TITLE -- WILL
BE PUBLISHED BY HARPER TEEN,
ALSO IN MAY.
HER FAVORITE AUTHOR IS LUCILLE
CLIFTON.
YES!
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND AS FURTHER EVIDENCE OF HER
UTTER FEARLESSNESS, SHE WAS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AN 8th GRADE
ENGLISH TEACHER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IN PRINCE GEORGES COUNTY,
MARYLAND.
THE PANEL LOVED THE SPARK AND
CRACKLE, HER ENERGY AND
PURPOSE^, THE MUSICALITY OF THE
NARRATIVE AND VERSE.
AGAIN, FROM CO-CHAIR MARIA
SALVADOR:  THE POET X PRESENTS
AN AUTHENTIC STORY IN LANGUAGE
THAT SCREAMS TO BE READ ALOUD,
JUST AS THE AMARA'S OWN POETRY
DOES.
LIKE MANY YOUNG PEOPLE JIAMARA
SEEMS SIMULTANEOUSLY SEEN AND
INVISIBLE IN HER WORLD.
READERS, PLEASE WELCOME
ELIZABETH ACEVEDO, WINNER OF THE
WALTER TEEN AWARD FOR "THE POET
X."
[ APPLAUSE ]
] ]   GOOD AFTERNOON.
SORRY FOR NOT FOLLOWING
DIRECTIONS.
I'VE GOT HEELS ON.
I CAN ONLY GO SO FAR, DOING THE
BEST I CAN.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE SEEN ME
SPEAK BEFORE, YOU KNOW I OFTEN
GO OFF THE CUFF.
I WANTED TO TRY SOMETHING NEW SO
I'M GOING TO READ THINGS I
WROTE.
MOSTLY.
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY,
TO BE IN THIS SPACE.
I FEEL LIKE I'M IN THE
INTERSECTION OF SEVERAL PARTS OF
MY LIFE.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ALL SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT LINDA SUE SAID.
I TAUGHT 8th GRADE ENGLISH IN
PRINCE GEORGES COUNTY, MARYLAND.
OH, YEAH, SHOUT OUT TO THE
TEACHERS IN THE ROOM, RIGHT?
I TAUGHT AT A SCHOOL THAT WAS
78% LATINX, 18% BLACK.
IT WAS A COOL THAT NEVER HAD A
LATIN X TEACHER TEACH A LATIN
SUBJECT.
THEY NEVER HAD A LATINA TEACHING
THERE AT ALL AND THERE WAS A
CONNECTION I FELT WITH MY
STUDENTS THAT WENT BEYOND JUST
WITHSTANDING IN FRONT OF THE
ROOM.
THE REASON I GOT SCHOLARSHIPS TO
UNDERGRAD, THAT I WAS ABLE TO
LEAVE THE COMMUNITY I LEFT WHICH
WAS AT TIMES A ROUGH COMMUNITY
WAS BECAUSE OF MY LOVE FOR
READING BECAUSE I WAS A
VORACIOUS READER AND I CAME
THROUGH A TEACHING PROGRAM THAT
I WASN'T SURE PREPARED ME TO DO
THE JOB I HAD, WHICH WAS TO
STAND IN FRONT OF 150, 13
13-16-YEAR-OLDS AND TEACH THEM
HOW TO READ.
MANY OF WHOM WERE ON A 5th
GRADE READING LEVEL, AND THE
ONLY THING THAT I HAD AS A
GUIDING LIGHT WAS I HAVE TO
TEACH THEM HOW TO LOVE READING.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT OBJECTIVES.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT NO STATE
TESTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE F.S.
WHAT THE F.A.S.T.
IS.
WHAT I KNOW --
[ APPLAUSE ]
WHAT I KNOW IS THAT IF THEY LOVE
TO READ, THEY WILL FIGURE IT
OUT.
RIGHT?
AND THAT WAS THE ONE THING THAT
KEPT ME GOING.
AND I HAD THIS STUDENT WHO WAS
REAL SLICK AT THE MOUTH, ALWAYS
HAD SOMETHING SMART TO SAY.
THE KIND OF KID WHO IF YOU'RE A
TEACHER YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
LIKE THAT'S REALLY APPROPRIATE
AND ON THE INSIDE, YOU'RE LIKE,
YOU'RE SO WITTY.
I WISH I COULD AFFIRM THIS PART
OF YOU, RIGHT?
CLASSROOM MANAGEMENT DOES NOT
ALLOW ME TO DO THAT.
AND THE STUDENT WOULD TELL ME,
I'M NOT A READER.
AND I ASKED HER ONE DAY, WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU WANT?
LIKE, WHAT BOOK CAN I GET?
WHAT WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN?
BECAUSE I HAD PUT EVERYTHING IN
FRONT OF HER I THOUGHT IT WAS
COOL.
I WAS GIVING HER HUNGER GAMES,
TWILIGHT, WHATEVER IS EXCITING
AT THE TIME.
SHE SAID I DON'T CARE ABOUT NO
SPARKLY VAMPIRES.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT KILLING NO
KIDS FOR FOOD, RIGHT?
LIKE...
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHERE ARE THE BOOKS ABOUT US?
AND SO I WENT OUT AND I BOUGHT
JULIO ALVAREZ, I GOT NIKKI
GRIMES AND JACQUELINE WOODSON.
I GOT ALL THESE BOOKS I HAD WHEN
I WAS HER AGE THAT FELT LIKE I
WAS SPEAKING TO MY EXPERIENCES.
WITHIN TWO WEEKS THE STUDENT WHO
TOLD ME SHE WAS NOT A READ
FINISHED I'VE REG I PUT IN FRONT
OF HER AND SHE LOOKED AT ME AND
SAID, WHAT'S NEXT?
THAT'S ALL MY BOOKS, AND MY
TEACHER BUDGET.
I'M LIKE WE'RE DONE HERE BUT
THOSE TWO QUESTIONS, THAT WAS
THE FIRST SPARK I HAD:  MAYBE I
CAN WRITE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
I'D BEEN A POET FOR MANY YEARS
BUT I DID NOT EVER WRITE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC BUT HERE WAS THIS
STUDENT WHO WAS ASKING ME,
WHAT'S NEXT?
AND THIS MOMENT OF:  WHY NOT ME?
WHY CAN'T I BE NEXT?
HERE I AM TRYING TO TEACH THEM A
LOVE OF READING.
I KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO READ.
I KNOW HOW TO WRITE.
I LOVE THE BOOKS THEY'RE
READING, I CAN FIGURE THIS OUT
SO IT WAS REALLY THAT SPARK OF
BEING AN EDUCATOR AND WANTING TO
SEE MY KIDS AND WANTING THEM TO
SEE THEMSELVES THAT PUSHED ME
FORWARD.
IT WAS IN THIS CAPACITY AS A
TEACHER THAT I WAS ABLE TO BRING
SO MANY BOOKS INTO CLASS THAT I
WOULD READ OUT LOUD, AND SOME OF
MY FAVORITE BOOKS TO READ WERE
WALTER DEAN MYERS BOOKS, PARTLY
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO NEW YORK AT
TIMES, RIGHT?
LIKE, 145th STREET IS ONE OF
THE MOST HARLEM BOOKS IN THE
WORLD AND I LOVE BEING ABLE TO
BE LIKE I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
Y'ALL, KIDS, BUT I'M GOING TO
ENJOY THIS PROCESS, RIGHT?
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL FOR ME TO HAVE
KIDS DISCOVER MONSTER AND
REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST READ
MONSTER TO TALK ABOUT SLAM AND
THE POWER OF THAT BOOK AND THE
POWER OF BASKETBALL AND SPORTS
IN OUR LIVES ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
COME FROM CERTAIN COMMUNITIES,
WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE HERE ARE THE
EXIT TICKETS.
HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE AND BE ABLE
TO CONNECT IN THAT WAY AND SO I
WAS SO THANKFUL, RIGHT, TO DO
THAT JOB.
BUT I ALSO KNEW I WANTED TO
FOCUS ON CREATIVE WRITING, AND
IN 2012 AFTER TWO YEARS OF
TEACHING, I LEFT TO GO TO THE,
TO GET MY MFA IN CREATIVE
WRITING AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND.
MY FIRST INTERNSHIP AND THE ONLY
INTERNSHIP I'VE EVER HELD WAS
HERE AT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
IN THE POETRY AND LITERATURE
CENTER UPSTAIRS SO THE FIRST
EVENT I WENT TO WAS NA A TASHA,
THE POLE LAUREATE, READING ON
THIS STAGE.
SHE WAS SO COOL.
SHE CAME FROM THE BACK.
WHEN I WALKED IN HERE TODAY I
WAS LIKE OH, SNAP.
ABOUT TO GET MY NATASHA ON,
RIGHT?
BUT THAT IT FEELS LIKE A HOME
COMING TO BE IN THIS SPACE, TO
BE RECEIVING THIS AWARD, TO BE
LOOKING AT THE YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
THIS AREA, IN THIS RAM, TO KNOW
THAT I WAS -- ROOM TO KNOW THAT
I WAS WRITING FOR YOU ALL IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
I WANT TO JUST TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE BEFORE I HOP OFF STAGE.
I WAS WRITING YOUNG ADULT IN
SECRET.
THE PROGRAM THAT I WAS IN DID
NOT FEEL LIKE ONE WHERE I COULD
BRING IN CHILDREN'S LITERATURE,
AND IT BE RECEIVED WELL.
THAT WHEN YOU ARE IN THE HIGH
ARTS, OR THE FINE ARTS, THERE
ARE VERY SPECIFIC IDEAS OF WHAT
THAT HAS TO SOUND LIKE SO I WAS
WRITING ON THE METRO UP TO GREEN
BELT.
I WAS WRITING IN BETWEEN
TEACHING.
I WAS WRITING WHEN I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE GRADING.
I WAS DOING THIS PROJECT THAT I
HAD NO IDEA IF IT HAD AN
AUDIENCE.
I DID NOT KNOW WHO WOULD READ
IT.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF THE INDUSTRY
WAS ABLE TO HANDLE SOMETHING
THAT WAS SO DAMN DOMINICAN AND
SO AFRO-DOMINICAN AND SO NEW
YORK.
I KNEW I WANTED TO READ IT BUT I
DIDN'T KNOW IF THERE WAS A
READER SHIP FOR THIS THING THAT
I WORKED ON FOR YEARS AND THEN
IN 2014, WALTER DEAN MYERS'
SEMINAL OP ED, WHERE ARE THE
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN CHILDREN'S
BOOKS WAS PUBLISHED AND I READ
THAT AND I KEPT MY EYE OUT AND I
THOUGHT:  OH, WAIT, WAIT.
I THINK SOMETHING MIGHT CHANGE
AND THEN "WE NEED DIVERSE BOOKS"
WAS FOUNDED AND I USED MY LITTLE
MFA MONEY WHAT WAS LEFT OF IT
AND DONATED NOT BECAUSE I WANTED
TO BE AT THE FRONT OF THE LINE
BUT BECAUSE I KNEW:  THIS IS A
GAME-CHANGER.
THIS IS A GAME-CHANGER.
EVERYONE SEES WHAT I SAW IN MY
CLASSROOM.
WE NEED TO BRING THESE BOOKS
FORWARD.
FORTH AND SO I'M SO HONORED THAT
IT'S THIS AWARD THAT I AM
RECEIVING TODAY.
THAT IT'S ALL OF THESE
CONNECTIONS THAT BRING ME INTO
THIS ROOM.
I WAS EMBOLDENED TO KEEP WRITING
BECAUSE I KNEW I WAS NO LONGER
ALONE.
I KNEW THAT THE STORY I WAS
WRITING HAD A HOME.
RIGHT?
IT FELT LIKE A BATTLE CRY OF
FOLKS THAT WERE RATTLING THE
CAGES AND DEMANDING TO BE LET
IN.
IT WAS A VIVID REMINDER ON A
DAILY BASIS THAT THERE WAS NOT
ONLY ROOM FOR ME AND MY STORIES
IN PUBLICKING, PUBLISHING BUT
THERE WAS A
NEED FOR THE KIND OF STORIES I
WANTED TO TELL AND FOR WHO I
WANTED TO TELL THEM TO.
THE POET, ESSAYIST AND MUSIC
CRITIC RAKEEB HAS A QUOTE
APARTMENT CHANCE THE RAPPER.
EVERY TIME I RAID IT IT MAKES MY
SPINE THRUM.
WHEN I FIRST READ IT HE WAS
CONSIDERING HIP HOP AND IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I
APPLY IT TO BUT HE WROTE -- HE,
MEANING CHANCE THE RAPPER, MAKES
MUSIC FACING HIS PEOPLE, WHILE
ALSO LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN FOR
EVERYONE ELSE TO TRY TO WORK
THEIR WAY IN.
IT WAS THIS KIND OF THINKING,
THIS INTENSE FOCUS ON NOT
TRANSLATING MYSELF, ON NOT
ITALICIZING OR OTHERING MYSELF,
OR NOT USING KID GLOVES WITH MY
AUDIENCE AND TRUSTING THEY WOULD
DO THE WORK.
IT WAS THAT KIND OF THINKING
THAT LED ME TO WRITE SOMETHING
THAT FELT INCREDIBLY HONEST.
EVEN AT A TIME WHEN I HAD NO
IDEA WHO WOULD READ IT.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF ANY PUBLISHER
WOULD WANT IT.
IT SEEMS INCREDIBLY SPECIAL THAT
THE EDITOR WHO ENDED UP PICKING
THIS BOOK, WHO ENDED UP USHERING
ME THROUGH MY DEBUT, WAS
ROSEMARY BROSNAN, THE EDITOR FOR
MANY YEARS OF WALTER DEAN MYERS.
IT FEELS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THAT SHE WAS THE PERSON WHO DID
THIS WORK WITH ME, WHO WAS THE
FIRST EDITOR TO REPLY TO MY
AGENT AND SAY:  YES, YES, THIS
BOOK, RIGHT?
SHE WAS TELLING ME JUST
YESTERDAY WE WERE TEXTING SHE
WAS LIKE I WAS SO IN AWE OF
WALTER.
I LEARNED SO MUCH FROM HIM.
AND I LIKE TO THINK THAT MAYBE
WALTER LEARNED SOME FROM HER AND
THAT AAM THE BENEFICIARY OF ALL
THAT LEARNING, THANK GOODNESS,
RIGHT?
SOMEBODY DID THAT WORK.
ROSEMARY IS NOT ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY BUT I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
I BROUGHT HER INTO THE ROOM,
THAT I SAID HER NAME HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO WANT TO JUMP ON TRENDS
SOMETIMES.
THERE WERE EDITORS I SPOKE TO
THAT SAID THINGS OH, I LOVE THE
LATINX FLAVOR AS IF THIS WAS A
SEASONING THAT I SPRINKLED ON A
NOVEL AND NOT WHO I AM OR WHAT
I'M WRITING AND ROSEMARY WAS NOT
THAT PERSON.
SHE'S SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN DOING
THE WORK AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE
FOLKS THAT THIS AWARD IS NOT
MINE ALONE.
THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN CHUMP
YUNING DIVERSITY FOR YEARS HAVE
BEEN HERE AND WE HAVE TO SAY
THEIR NAME AND REMIND OURSELVES
THEY'RE HERE.
I DO FEEL LIKE TODAY IS AN
ARRIVAL OF SORTS.
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
KNOW THEY WERE GUIDING MY STEPS
ARE FINALLY IN THE ROOM FOR ME
TO THANK THEM.
AS SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES THE
ANCESTORS WALK WITH US, I HOPE
THAT MR. WALTER DEAN MYERS IS IN
THE ROOM TODAY.
I HOPE HE KNOWS THE WORK WE ARE
DOING IN HIS NAME.
I HOPE HE FEELS THAT I'M WRITING
IN HIS LINEAGE, THAT I CHOOSE TO
SENSOR CHARACTERS AND STORIES
THAT ARE VERY RARELY CENTERED.
I CHOOSE TO READ ABOUT
CHARACTERS OF COLOR WITH
TENDERNESS AND LOVE AND A
PRECISION OF LANGUAGE AND A
RIGOR OF IDEAS THAT W DE.
THAT I LEARNED A BOOK COULD LOVE
ME BACK BY READING BOOKS LIKE
HIS.
THAT I HOPE I DO THAT EVERY
SINGLE TIME I WRITE MY OWN
STORY.
I DON'T SUBSCRIBE TO THE IDEA
THAT WRITING IS THERAPY.
I BELIEVE THERAPY IS THERAPY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DO HOWEVER BELIEVE THAT THE
POWER OF WRITING LOVE ONTO THE
PAGE AND FEEDING THAT IN THE
DIRECTION OF AN AUDIENCE EVEN IF
IT'S JUST AN AUDIENCE OF ONE,
YOURSELF, IS PIVOTAL.
I DO BELIEVE WHAT MR. MYERS ONCE
SAID:  I WRITE BOOKS FOR THE
TROUBLED BOY I ONCE WAS AND FOR
THE BOY WHO LIVES WITHIN ME
STILL.
IT'S WHAT I DO.
AND SO WHILE I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WRITING IS THERAPY, I DO
BELIEVE THAT WRITING CAN BE
HEALING, AND IT'S OFTEN AS
HEALING FOR THE WRITER AS IT IS
FOR THE READER.
I HOPE TO KEEP WRITING FOR
MYSELF, FOR MY COMMUNITY, FOR MY
FORMER AND FUTURE STUDENTS, FOR
ALL MY BELOVEDS.
I HOPE TO WRITE THEM ON THE
PAGE.
I WANT TO BUILD A PANTHEON OF
CHARACTERS AS RICH AND NUANCED
AS THE PEOPLE I COME FROM.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE -- AND
WHILE I DON'T SEE AWARDS AND
STICKERS AS THE END ALL-BE ALL,
I DO SEE THEM AS A KIND OF
PERMISSION.
A KIND OF CHEERLEADING, AS IF
FOLKS FROM DIFFERENT WALKS OF
LIFE LOOK AT MY LEGACY OF
LETTERS, AT THIS THING THAT I AM
BUILDING, AND ARE SAYING IN
GILDED CRIES --
[ SPEAKING LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH ]
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO TELLING
OUR STORIES THE ONLY DIRECTION
TO KEEP OUR EYES IS ONWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
AWARD.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE, AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
] ]   OKAY, FOLLOWING CHRIS,
LINDA SAW, JEWELL, AND LIZ, AND
THE SYMPOSIUM EARLIER IS A
SET-UP FOR FAILURE.
LET'S JUST SAY THAT.
OKAY.
HAVING GOTTEN THAT OUT, I'M
GOING TO BE EVEN A MOOD-KILLER
FURTHER TO SAY, I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU A FEW RULES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT AT THIS POINT, I JUST WANT
TO SAY, REPEAT ONE THING THAT
CHRIS SAID, THAT REALLY MEANS A
LOT.
EVERYTHING YOU SAID MEANS A LOT.
BUT WE ARE GOING PLACES AS A
FAMILY.
I THINK WE NEED TO KEEP THAT IN
MIND, BECAUSE WE ARE A FAMILY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY, SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
AUTHORS AND THE JUDGES PLEASE
STAY HEAR FOR HERE FOR SOME
PHOTOS AND
WE'LL HAVE THE AUTHORS GO INTO
THE WHITTALL PAVILION FOR
BOOK-SANING SO ONE FAVOR THAT
WE'RE ASKING BECAUSE THERE ARE
STUDENTS IN THE ROOM AND I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE DYING TO GET BACK
TO THEIR SCHOOLS FOR WORK --
[ LAUGHTER ]
THAT WE LET THEM GO TO THE HEAD
OF THE LINE, IF THEY HAVE
PURCHASED A BOOK AND NEED A BOOK
SIGNED.
AND ONE OTHER QUESTION -- ONE
THING TO ASK IS, IF YOU DON'T
MIND, WE DON'T REALLY HAVE TIME
FOR INDIVIDUAL PHOTOS AND A LOT
OF PERSONALIZATION, SO IT REALLY
IS JUST A BOOK-SIGNING, WITH
EXCEPTIONS, I'M SURE.
SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
COMING.
THANK YOU TO THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
I MEAN, "WE NEED DIVERSE BOOKS"
IS SO HAPPY TO PARTNER THE
SYMPOSIUM AND THE AWARDS
CEREMONY MEANS SO MUCH TO ALL OF
US.
SO THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
SUPPORTING US.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[ END OF PROGRAM ]